Oh
Reminder to tweet Kohai
Hey for gore I for gore
That's the wrong account
I
Need to get my
Stuff
Oh man a cutscene
Wait wait wait, I still have the pulse. I'm stupid
Oh
That was the fastest oh my gosh, there's dialogue too
Okay as Pharaoh in real nice the preposterous preposterous now that my brother has fallen I'm the king
Listen cold bird with or without a coordination ceremony blah blah blah. Huh, you're just nothing without our help
Just try to get out of here on your own
Silence Garrett. We're all in the presence of the king you are to serve as majesty
Wow
Wait the game started automatically it's a cutscene
Bravo fennel nice Bravo those creatures never had a chance a surprise attack within the snowstorm. Maybe they're after
Amanda cold bird. Maybe the demons are after the arch arch arch arch
The arch is a possibility
Do you think the arch is worth something to them Ryan?
What they came to get my arch
No cold bird do not let them take it. They'll use it for no good
This is going too fast for me to actually be a this
What a relief the arch is safe
Amelia your leg
Ah and my nickname is supposed to be the sword princess, right?
Anyhow commander was the rest of the group
Yes
Oh, is that asperilla relas? Oh, he did he did did wait just disappeared dead. Oh, who could take down a night so easily?
Greetings, I am the demon as ass. I'll hazard nonsense. The demons were destroyed a long time ago
And yet here I am right in front of you
But I'm afraid I simply don't have time for this nonsense. Let's get down to business
I am here to ask you for an object which you call the arch
Yes by all means go ahead and take it take anything you wish just please spare my life
No, your majesty you must not do that
I'm sorry
All I can give you in return is a painless death
You all have to live with it. Oh, you're a funny guy, huh?
You bastard, how could you?
Garrett Amelia get ready. You must escape from Arteca Castle. Let's everyone in fill Gaia. No, what has happened here?
Oh God the commander I'm sure the demon took down others as well
Oh
Hey, you're a bigger coward than I thought
Huh, what are you talking about? Why are you calling me a coward? You have no courage
You're probably thinking of a way to defeat the demon even now, aren't you?
Of course no matter how what it takes I'll kill that thing
So you caught throwing your life away courage
We will not be able to defeat them yet. I know it's hard to admit
Look at your terrible wound
It's not as bad as yours. I'll mean I I won't hear of it
You think that fighting is an unbeatable enemy is courage. I don't agree with that
Then what do you consider the brave thing to do?
I hate to interrupt your tender moment run Garrett
Gosh, I'm speed running this
What what are you doing El Mina I can't get away with this wound
Open the gate. Oh Mina
You're the one who said wasting your life is not courage
We gain nothing from fighting the demon I
Fight to protect something important to me
I won't gain anything, but I will not lose anything will gain nothing from violence
But I can at least protect what's mine
Protecting something important is not a waste of life
Here I don't want to lose you
Nor are you open the gate. Oh, Mina. I'll fight with you
Open the gate. Oh, Mina
You must tell the world what has happened here
Don't worry about me. I have no intention of dying here. I am the sword princess remember
Besides the ribbon I wrapped around your arm was expensive
I don't care about I can't die until I get that back
There you are it was not easy finding you. Oh
Wait, I missed that like have courage go on Garrett take this memory with you
I
Deliver the Fenriel spirit to our friends and then that was too fast. I will return the ribbon to you soon
Keep running don't look back
There's no way out ha ha ha ha ha you are noble and beautiful
Okay, you didn't have to add that last part can't you see my body is trembling with your
trembling
I
This is where he's screaming no, I can feel it I can feel it
Also is is the a few years later is the is the ps2 loud. Can you hear it?
Push that I'm playing on original console by the way
Wait, how do I move
Wait, how do I go to next game new game?
Circle oh
Thank you
Yes
If you're referring to the console then no, I can't hear the console good
First check your system settings if you don't need to change anything or after you've finished with the setup
Press the start button to begin the game. Let's start it anyways. I'm pretty sure I set everything up
If you set the vibration to on you can stop the vibration by pushing the R3 button while the controller is vibrating
Yeah, this should be good I
Saw this and I was like what the hell is this?
Turns out this game was supposed to have voice acting, but they took out the entirety of the voice acting
Screen saver. Oh, let's do it off. Okay start
And I just left that part there
I
Have voices when you have can have mercy
I'm gonna turn it up for me
Flowers have so much to say if you listen they told me I would see everyone again girl who loves flowers
We've arrived early didn't we it was because my lady rushed
I
What is being early a bad thing
He's not blaming you anyway, it should be any time now
Look someone's coming speak of the devil use no, that's what I'm saying
I
Looks pretty good for an older game. That's because I'm using the retro tank on it. I work so hard for you senpai
I have put filters on here and
And it up it is upscaled
Let me catch my breath. It's not a pull not polite to keep a girl waiting
At last we meet again
Prologue one the boy traveling alone press X button
I
Have one too the world has become a wasteland the beautiful green of the globe has faded gradually to brown
Okay, okay. Yeah, okay. Yeah
I was gonna say so guy. Yeah, but I think it's for guy
People have banded together for survival uniting to fend off the harsh elements the menace menace of monsters
Those few who traveled the withered world seeking adventure are called wanderers a
Young wanderer is staying at surf village in the frontier
This is supposed to be a cat like a Western RPG though. He looks quite young. He is skilled beyond his years
What does the young wanderer seek traveling the world?
Hey, you can finish up now
Thank you very much the ranch looks twice as big now that you've cleaned it I
Hired you through our village chief. I didn't expect you to work so hard
Oh, I still don't know your name. I keep calling you boy. Tell me. What's your name?
Senpai for nostalgia sake. Do you want to just keep the name that they made or did you want to rename them?
Keep the name
Oh, you wanted to be
Yeah, we'll keep the name
It's flickering on my side a little bit, but that's okay
Okay
Oh
Keep the name then
Since this is many people's childhoods, this is my first time playing wild aren't
I'm playing it currently on the original hardware
I inserted the disc and everything and I'm
Capturing it through a capture card and I am also upscaling it through a device called a retro tank
so
That it looks
Very upscaled and I've added some filters
So that senpai's won't get like this flickering effect that I I have a little bit, but it still looks amazing a
Retro tink
Tinker like a tinkerer
Is this a jet engine ps2 yeah, I'm borrowing a friend's ps2 right now because I was testing my ps2
earlier in the week and then
Yesterday it just decided to stop working and would not turn on and I was
Oh
Yeah, it just it just didn't turn on
So I I really had to rush out and grab grab
Grab like borrow another one, but the issue is that I have a lot of games
I want to play on the ps2 and since I'm borrowing this ps2. That's a problem because I
Have to give it back
Well, maybe I can buy a new one
But I worked really hard to get this to work because I don't think this game I
don't think it's it's
Available on PC. I don't think they ported it to anywhere. I
Don't think they ported this game to anywhere
Hmm, I don't think they ported it anywhere
So the only way
On
On to play this game, I believe is either I think
You have to buy it and I have a copy of it of it right here in my hand
Hmm
So I
Have it I have a physical copy of it
This game is rare and expensive it's 200 US dollars
And you get it well, I have a friend
Who um
Okay, this sounds this sounds this isn't gonna sound unbelievable
And you might not believe me but it's
One of my gal pals
Wanted to downsize things. I think she was she's trying to do like minimalism or something
But she basically has every single fucking like
Like system ever and so
She said hey, I heard you're doing streaming now. Do you want to have these I want to get rid of them quickly and so I
kind of
Adopted this entire collection
Which is insane
Which is fucking insane right
Yeah, all for free because she really wanted it
She really wanted it gone
How much did you get a lot? Let's just say I got a lot
Yeah, getting rid of it is crazy, but I feel like she just wanted it gone and like
and like
For someone to actually use it so yeah, she was really nice to give it to me like your entire collection
To me so I have a few games here that are considered very rare and I'd like to play them with Senpai
Any Silent Hill was it just ps2 games or games from other consoles games from other consoles too like a really big collection
But
That's why I that's why I um
That's why I I kind of like I really treasure all these cuz like they're they're from my precious friend, right?
Does that make sense like all of these games are like my treasures
I think the only game that I bought
Got any dot-hack games I was just gonna say the only game that I bought recently are the dot-hack games
Are the dot-hack games one of a friend of a friend of mine a
Friend of a friend of mine
Wanted to get rid of
Of
There they're like
PS2 games and like I was looking through the ps2 games and I saw that they had all of the dot-hack games and
They were going to get rid of the they said that they were oh they were gonna offer me
All four I think it was four. Yeah four of the dot-hack games. I already had two
But they were gonna give me all of the dot-hack game for only a hundred dollars and so I said yes, I
Said yes, so I would I have all of them
Hold on I'm gonna fix my model of it
Including to you I have all of them all of them
So
I'm not quite surprised because it seems like a lot of people even if they have like a really rare collection of stuff
They seem to just want to get rid of it quickly, you know
So that's when I was like oh, okay, I guess they didn't want the trouble of
Of like
Trying to find like a buyer or someone who would buy it for like a certain price, right?
Oh
So yeah, I got wild arms I got I don't have
The original wild arms I have ultra cold F. I kind of want to start at the beginning
I have two and three and I think I have I think
Don't know if I have four, but I think I have five
So I have all of the Ohio arms
It was a part of the collection that my friend gave me
And this is my first time playing on the ps2 with
Everyone so this is my first time actually
Um
Like playing it on stream I
Did play it a bit. I was playing devil devil summoner
How long it would take for us to complete the series way too fucking long let's just say that it's way too fucking long
Oh, I thought you chose this because it was a favorite. I wanted to start from a beginning area
There will be no emulating here at all
So every game that I play that will be retro is either one that has been ported to PC or
It's on original hardware, okay
So
So we have plenty of games to go through, but there's a ball also a bunch of games
And I want to go through that our newer too
Okay
And Rudy is what I'll call you it's a good name. That's a good strong name
Let's hope that ps2 never dies one jinx it no jinx it knock on wood
You're a great guy Rudy
You have power and a tireless work ethic
Best of all you took care of my horses as though you understand their feelings
Why don't you stay in this village and work for us? I'm kidding. I know you're a wanderer
Here's the payment for your time it's not much that's all I can afford
Obtained keo berries time fly say hello to the village chief for me
Thank you very much for your work today. I will ask you for help again. I'm sure
Horse talk to horse
In my brain
Would you like to save today? Yeah, sure save here. Yeah
Nice
Look
This village is desolate now. Well once it's sold it's sold in an effective medical
Man minute medicina. Well, I can't talk medicinal herb herb from the berry cave west of here
The name of the herb was holy berry amazing power to heal any wounds immediately
The cave was sealed by our village chief. It had become a dangerous place full of nasty monsters
This village will become rich someday if we can harvest holy berries again
Did he say west?
I
Mean
I've worked 20 years in this village the time needed for plants to bud has been getting
Long longer year after year heard from others the same thing happened in other villages
Rumor that this entire world is heading towards destruction may not be a false rumor
Thank you for your hard work, you know about holy berries
Let's let them explain it to me again
That's what I thought a holy berry is very effective herb which people say grows in a cave near here
When used any injured person can be healed and their strengths revived if only I had a holy berry
No, it's nothing nevermind
No, tell me what's up?
My father's the strongest man around you may not look like it right now. He was injured and has to rest in home
It's true. He's a strong and brave man who can be any monster. That's why I want to heal his wound
I want my brave father back
Oh
Sweet
Oh Rudy wait up. It's an older lady
Hello Rudy my husband is in his office over there, but you can rest upstairs first if you like yeah
I
Room upstairs has been prepared for you as usual. Please rest a while
I get to like it all this is so nice
Nice there's another room here
It's a barrel
I feel I feel like it does have like that wild west feel
Oh
Hello Rudy you seem to be settling in well
I understand the horses are thriving under your care
There must be something I can give you to show you show our gratitude
Hmm
The world is decaying Rudy even here in surf village
Once this village benefited from the herbs we collected from the berry cave west of the village
That was so long. That was long ago. Give me Rudy. Sometimes an old man's mind wanders
In the storage area next to this room you'll find our supply of bombs
Use them to explore the berry cave. Please take them. They're worthless to the village now, but they might be useful to you
No, he's gonna give us bombs
Bombs give me bombs. No, that's not bomb. Oh chess. Give me obtained tool bomb
A bomb can set you set at your feet by pressing
Square after setting it and allowing time to pass and breaks items such as wooden boxes or rocks
Also, if you set bombs close to each other, they explode at the same time and can destroy obstacles in a wide area
You can set a maximum of eight bombs
so, um
Village chief mr. Tallam and you've got a serious problem
Uh, so do I get unlimited bombs or do I have to find these bombs?
It's all right, please continue. Tell me what happened
It's Tony
But I forgot which one
It's Tony. He broke the village ban. He went to the berry cave
What why would he do something so foolish?
What should we do?
Berry cave used to be the source of great medicinal herb now. It's just a den of monsters
I don't know what we should do
In any case keep it a secret for now. I'll explain to the villagers later. You don't want to start a panic
This goes for you too. You shouldn't tell anyone about Tony breaking the village man
You don't need anyone running off and playing hero. We need to come up with a plan
Yeah, the plan is me
We are the plan we are the plan we have bombs. What else do we need?
Would you like to save? Yeah, let's save here too
Oh, that's like sneaking. Okay
West never eat shredded wheat
The search system seeks undiscovered towns caves and so forth
Press the square button to use this radar
Discovered locations are shown as symbols on the screen and may be entered by facing the place and pressing the x button
Tony appeared to have headed for the berry cave to the west of the search village
Use the search system to find the berry cave
This
Wow
Am I strong enough for this?
Shoot horse special I know shoot
No, you go no you go
Nice
That's for adventures. Oh damn
Oh wait, am I blocking it too much?
Best best yes
Yes, the tiny corner, okay
The village chief speak with you if he has then you already know I can't believe it. Oh, Tony is all right
I'll turn my back for one second under our law all who live in surf village are prohibited from going into this cave
What should we do
I got it. You're not from our village, right? Therefore you are not bound by our law
Well, you risk your life in going to the cave. Please find Tony and bring him back to me
Yeah
Thank you. I'm forever in your debt
This advanced payment of reward your reward. Please take it obtained lucky card times three
Obtained party item
My big me grand seal migrant
Wow, I can't read I literally can't read
Fine I can't read sometimes it happens
You can now
Now you have one migrant seal and the encounter cancel system is available when ea ends
Encounter camps and me and c sense says a monster a exclamation point
Press the
Circle button when you see the point on screen to avoid a battle. It's quite useful when you're in a hurry
There's no escaping a battle once it starts remember that
When you avoid a battle your ENC gauge decreases make sure you to be careful
All right, all right
I don't care we fighting everyone
What the heck is this thing
You
Baking breath, oh no, no, he's baking
Let him cook
Oh
My ht went back up again nice, but my bit is 60%
I love gun what a useful tool
Please use more gun now you go now you go
Goodbye you little shit
Did he run
Yeah
So how many bombs do I have like unlimited, right?
Once famous the very cave is now abandoned keep an eye out for the unknown creatures that roam its dark treacherous shafts
Shafts
Shafts, huh?
I can get a bomb now
Shoot
No, you go
Bye goodbye
Never mind never mind you were a coward
I gotta revive fruit
So how do I put bombs down again?
Anyone remember how to put square, okay
You
Yeah
Thank you
I
Oh
Goat
Yeah
Those bombs won't hurt you if you're next to them. Oh
Yay, I got up to level four
I think I am getting house back after the battles
Hey Betty
Oh, I can like okay, that's how the migrant stuff works. I'll fight you
Shoot
Upward
I heard the first game has like horrendous translation, which I think is probably part of its charm
In a shaft of an upward thrust in a shaft can I bomb this one?
No
Oh
More bombs and a bomb here a bomb here
Shoot I and his special attack gun
Oh nice gave you like a cool animation and stuff
I happened to my other bomb
And a nice bomb that came out
Oh
Yes shot
Ah you ran away
Oh
We love gun
What's this
Glimmering crystal spirit when you pick up orange gems your bit gauge replenishes by 10%
Um
Never mind no bomb
I want gun to work all the time
Baking breath he's cooking he's cooking me
Hahaha
As an American I feel immensely close to the main character can I bomb bomb this
Now
Oops I'm stuck
I
Think this game is kind of based off of like the wild west in America
This big foxes stop trying to bake me
Stop cooking who let him cook
I think if you hold X you can sprint in the straight line
Oh, oh fuck
Everyone keep out removal of the sign is punishable by law. I love sheath
It sounds like
I
Love breaking laws of shit
Okay, first we kill this tatsa worm
Oh
Don't thrust at me
Oh, I countered a bit nice guy
Oh
Inertia
Is my bit important
Inertia I love that like um
I love that video of the the professor. She has like such a heavy accent and she goes inertia
It is what he's healing you after battle. Oh shit
I
Yeah, I'm gonna need bit, huh? I would like to replenish bit
Can't pull conceit mysterious cloudy gem pick up white gems to restore one unit of your ence gauge
I love how this is the tutorial, but where the fuck am I?
Oh
Bam
Press X while next to a ladder and the character will grab the ladder
After you grab the ladder use the left analog stick to climb up or down
I
Want my stuff
Are there like lots of hidden rooms that was really hard to see
Oh
Look at me. I'm so strong now. I hit gotten hard
I my vits is back up
Wait, did I leave something behind oops
And
I'm obtained gimmel coin
The player can use one gimmel coin to save data even in place where there are no memory bird
Also, if the player loses a battle they can use a gimmel corn to choose whether they want to continue without losing stats
Okay, that sounds kind of important
I think our button might be able to spin the camera
Oh
Uh, maybe I'm not gonna spin that much though. Call hi go back. Okay
Uh
I'm gonna get motion sick
There's an item
The other way
Hmm
I
Like shooting oh, holy shit. I'm so strong now. Fuck. Yeah
I'm a menace to society. I'm quick draw
Ha ha 69
Oh
Was it this way wait, sorry I got confused about where I was
Oh, yeah, there is a way there. Wow, I'm stupid
I
Am I
Thank you for the two
I fell didn't I
Oh
Uh, sorry
Sorry, let me read this again
Uh, thank you, darlin. Be se pi mercy. This is for the two dollar tip mercy. This isn't a laughing matter
You got to work up and down the shaft seriously can't afford to get distracted when you thrust your sword
I have a sword. I have a gun. I'm shooting my shot
You can't succeed simply through a stroke of luck got a firmly grabs the situation at hand
I
Sorry, I got disoriented
And I get I don't know another game of coin
I think he shot the chest he shot
Sorry
You're gonna shoot on the chest, right?
Fuck did I fall off?
They're gonna shoot. Where do you want to shoot on the chest base?
I
Break these ones
No
Oh
Why is this all so easy to have like innuendos
It's so easy you just have a dirty mind mercy
No
No, are you
I
Got this game when it first came out it got delayed so many times. I almost forgot. I almost forgot. I almost for
I almost forgot I pre-ordered it
There we go
I almost forgot. I almost forgot. I pre-ordered it. Thank you. Okay. There we go. Anyways, uh
How old is this game shit
One is this good side. What is this?
Oh, wow 2005
Five
2005 Sony computer entertainment all rights reserved. Wow. Did they do pre-orders back then?
Yeah, shoot
2005 is not that old I feel like all of you guys are slightly
A little older in the older age bracket
Oh
Anyways, give me my bomb. Oh bomb. Yeah stuff tamed yellow card
Don't worry senpai. I love you even if you're old
Even if you're old and decaying
Oh
Hey
I still love you. I feel I'm feeling so bratty right now
I'm feeling so bratty right now
Um
Is there anything over here? Is this a secret area?
Oh stuff go away. I want my stuff open sesame no fairy
I did people well, I thought that was a bed
I
Thought that was a bed. I I think it's just one of those things with like, you know a bag sand
Yes, uh, it feels like a like a like a bag
I feel so strong. I feel so powerful
I look like pillows those sandbags look like pillows
So I just assumed that it was
It was like a bed it looks so comfy
Yeah open
Not the master
Oh
It's always the nectar I remember making fun of certain games that kept on saying nectar
Like finding nectar shooting our shot
Oh, hey, it's over here
You cannot blame me anymore
You cannot blame me anymore this game is doing it on purpose
Was there anything on this side? I'm kind of dumb right now. I don't know where I'm going senpai
There wasn't anything here right no, I don't think she'll
No, I was like wondering if there was like something behind the bed or something
Oh wait, there's a sign there
Getting a little bit motion sickness not gonna lie. It's a bit
Damn, I'm really like picking butts
My vint is back the camera's been is a little it's a little harsh. He's a little harsh not gonna lie
What's it say?
So
Short
What's it say watch out the ladders instead he do not hit
What do they mean do not hit and I hit it
I
Had I hit it I used a bomb on it
Oh, maybe the the the
Oh, there's three of them now
uh
What do you call it the really the the the holding down axe sprinting? Yes
Yeah
Inertia I actually don't know what that does
What does the inertia cancel do
Yes
Wow, we are so good at this
Are you cancer the counter-attack I think oh so
Oh
Die
Open the treasure box
Himmelforn
I
This piece too is so noisy it's so noisy
Man
I think you actually do more damage. Oh zero damage damn
That boys I think it's pretty I don't know it's pretty big
I don't know if senpais can hear it you can hear the look look from like the disc being read
Oh
Senpai
I was gonna sneeze
You
Hey here, Barry
I
Really want a ps2 slim because I hear it it's it's got like
It's better
Because um, I know a lot of speedrunners use it
So I kind of want a ps ps2 slim
200 gala
It's you okay, let's do a kid voice now. Sorry
It's you no, I can't do it. I'm sorry. It's you. Why are you here? Will you help me?
Your kid um, we're taking you home. Oh shit
Get out of here you little goblins literally zero
I was like I can't do it. I came here sir. I came here searching for something that will heal my father's wounds
I came here searching for something that will heal my father's wounds
I heard there's some there's an herb hidden deep within this cave that can heal any injury
I
I'm stuck. I don't know what to do because that huge rock is walking my progress
It seems the wall would break into pieces if it receives a series of impacts
One two three four five
Oh
Did I mean big series of impacts? Oh, is it eight bombs? I thought it was five my bad
I thought it was five bombs. I'm so still I'm so silly
Is this is this the first character story you played
um, I booted up the game
And this is the first character we see
Yeah
Yeah, that's nice
In alter f I think they forced into Rudy's story first. Oh pretty
I
Like trees
We're climbing
Oh, I can't reach it. Yeah, I jumped
Are you actually an evil little brat?
Thank you so very much
My father's gonna go die without a holy berry. He's gotta feel he's gotta get better. He's just gotta
I should be going I've got to get back and cure my father
Oh
What's going on here?
Oh, it's shaking love the uh controllers vibrating
Can we just release an agent evil? Oh boy
Oh
We angry
Let's see how could you all this they just wanted to bury you get hungry
also this map is huge
What are you what is that
it's the village chief oh they brought all their little like sickles and stuff
cute well now why do you always act so impossibly
even dog came no what are those called again they're like a little plows right
I don't know what they're called I'm very sorry but I wanted to heal my father
that's why I had to look for a holy berry
didn't you think of the possibility of you getting hurt or worse oh oh
phone is back is back safe because of you thank you oh shucks ain't got nothing
none of it an earthquake and a heroic rescue on the same day tell me did you
find any holy berries I felt I found one that matched the description the others
were all all wilted look here it is
chief chief we might be able to harvest those berries again that's the case it's
all because of Tony and Rudy to work they didn't go deep into the cave we
wouldn't know this holy berry existed in any case the most important thing is
that they came back safely let's discuss this back at the village
oh go get back here oh don't be weird no
not the dog not the bag what is that thing there's a monster trapped in the
bear cave an ancient Tom's can this be
not the dog
all right that's it rotting bees girls
nice
okay that's not bad Rudy can use the force ability lock on by consuming 25
fp lock on improves the power of attacks and hits the target more accurately by
using it with shot or cartridge however lock on while walk on his news you are
likely to get hit from your opponent depending on the situation you should
prioritize your action of attack or recovery let's walk on
oh I'm gonna just shoot I like shooting
no
nobody's around wait I know course
Item, force, let's force. Lock on. Let's try it.
Oh!
Drawing breath! Ewww!
Force! What's this?
Boost and shell. Right.
With this? Oh! Oh! Oh!
I should probably heal up.
Where's my item?
Yeah, we're good.
Force.
Come on! Let's do this!
Oh!
What's going on?
That can't be good.
Oh! Oh!
Is it finished? Did we win? It kind of didn't feel like we won.
It felt like something worse was going to happen.
The dog okay?
Just amazed. It's just amazed that you beat such a huge monster.
What's the matter?
Your power. Your power might cause grave misfortune to this village.
Where's the good boy?
Is my gun? Wait, what?
Is my gun too powerful? I knew it! Your arm! The legend speak of it!
It's been forbidden here for a thousand years! Unknown holy destructive power! Damn guns!
It's an unholy destructive power.
Why do you bring such a dangerous power to our village?
It terrifies me to even think of having such a thing used in our peaceful village.
It was caused because you used the arm?
It's true. I'm convinced it's because of your arm. The monster in the cave came back to life.
No! It can't! It's not true! It can't be because he used the power! He saved me!
You may be able to see Tony, but you can't fool us any longer.
Stop it! All of you, stop! Now is the time for Temptris' debate.
Grootie, thank you for rescuing Tony.
You have a danger you brought to our village and the carelessness used in it.
The buried cave is unacceptable. In our village, we respect peace, and a hazard like your arm is prohibited.
Under our law, you must allow us time to decide your fate in this village. Do you have any objections?
Can I say I object?
Can I just...
But it's... I thought it was just a gun.
Can we say I object?
Object! Excuse me! Excuse me! Object!
I cannot accept your objection.
You are not from our village. You wander from place to place, but this problem concerns Surf Village.
It isn't the right thing for you to let us decide what we're going to do.
Did I have choice?
Did I have choice? Is it just going to repeat the same thing?
Alright, let's object again everyone.
Man, I'll accept your objection. You are from... not from us.
No! No! No! No! Third time's a charm!
Bruh!
Never mind! Never mind, we're not allowed to object. We're not allowed to object.
Ten pa! Ten pa! I think we have to let them decide. What do you think?
I know that you... that... that we... now we... we saved this village and we brought back the Holy Berry.
But get dammit!
Literally no choice. They bamboozled me.
I'm glad you respect my decision. I will do my best to reach a verdict that everyone can agree on.
I will go back to Surf Village now. I cannot make a decision here.
I'm about to bomb your entire village right now.
The dog's alive!
Where are we saved?
He used his power to protect people fear and avoid him.
He didn't want such a power, but this destructive might of... is his.
Blah blah blah. Unaware of his inherent strength, he wanders to the wasteland searching his places in the world.
Wow, that was way too fast.
Now I can't get to save? Thank you.
Prologue 2. Treasure Hunter. Press X button.
Oh.
What a nice tune.
Is that Gattle Wand?
Huh.
Oh, it's a mouse! Okay.
This... these are the ruins of memory.
How much money do you pay for this information?
For the information on this dump?
It kind of looks like Gatomon, right?
Huh. What happened?
Handpan.
Huh. What handpan?
Do you know of this place?
I can't believe you don't. These ruins are rather famous. You believe someone's lying. Again.
Shut up. My gut is telling me that something good will come from this place.
Huh. This is obviously an intellectual one. I won't... I don't share your optimism.
I bet your name for this place would be the previously looted ruins of the dead.
Maybe then you wouldn't be having fun.
Even if there is some treasure. I mean, it's total junk.
I'm sorry. What do you think of that voice?
I do not think you can find anything worth the money you paid.
If you feel that way, don't come with me.
Oh, don't be so stubborn. You know that you'll need my help.
Like Nyantaro? I don't know what you're talking about. Nyantaro is totally different.
At any rate, we came this far. We should at least check it out.
I might find a clue about absolute power.
Absolute power and absolute destiny. I don't know.
What's this? It's a computer!
Hey, hantan, what is this?
No! No! No! Don't touch it!
Let me handle it. It should be treated well like this.
If you are the successor of memory, enter the correct descendants name and the way will be open.
Hmm, interesting. Is it asking us to enter a name?
Oh, shh. Maybe it is like the Nyantaro. Give me a second.
Uh, name is an important thing. Do you know the name intellectual one?
Don't get smirking me. I don't know it.
Alright. Well then, let's try it. Let's enter my name.
Okay, let's enter Jack. We're keeping the original names. Senpai.
Jack. No name matches.
He does look like a Jack. Do I look like a Mercy Senpai?
Well, I didn't really expect it. Why did I go back to my saloon accent?
Yes, I do look like a Mercy. I look like a cutie.
Smooth.
You look more like a Kohai than me. Oh, you look like a Senpai.
I wonder, um, guy? Senpais? Do you think if we entered some name here, the way would be open?
It would just be like a quick run? I don't know. What do you think?
Like, would it? Would it? Does it? No. Man.
Not the first time at least. Okay.
Since I don't, since I did not expect my name could be the password, I don't feel next.
I could try the Konami code.
Why are you done? There was a camp. An earthquake. You must be kidding me.
You know, I'm not going to lie to you. These, like, 3D models? Whoa!
I feel like I was in Mario for a second there.
Jack Van Bra. Brace. Master of the Sword. A tireless treasure hunter.
Apan is a windmouse.
His weapon is knowledge. His attitude is a fly in the ointment. Attitude? Yeah.
Whenever a danger awaits them, treasure hunters live for danger and thrive exploring ancient ruins.
Oh, he's Indiana Jones, got it.
Sorry, I'm going to look at the screen some more so I don't miss any text.
The treasure that Jack seeks is power with rises above all existence.
It is absolute power.
Where is it located?
The Dark Sword? The sealed magical power.
He searches earnestly. Unaware what it is.
Jack dreams of power. He dodges traps in the ancient ruins.
I was going to say, I really like the 3D models that they did.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, shit.
Since I learned force a little bit, can I do a special speed thing?
Balloon applesauce. Balloon?
Iplost? Like pipe?
Can I just attack?
It looks like a demon from SMT.
I know exactly which demon you're talking about. The one that has all the faces, right?
Really surprised to see this. Love this series. I feel like this series is a lot of people's...
Charizard.
He does look like that. He looks like that guy.
Which is apparently an amalgamation of stuff that you can find in the abyss.
I am...
Engaging in battle is not the only way a character can lose HP. Triggering traps or releasing poison will also decrease HP.
While damage from traps and poison will not prevent a player from engaging in battle, entering a battle with low HP will make it harder to win.
If a character receives damage from traps or poison, try to recover HP quickly.
The stone pillar looks dubious. A device somewhere might make it work. Maybe those stones in the corner?
Let me think for a second.
I do not like this.
If you hold R2, then press X harder to...
Then press X, the character will survey the surrounding areas for traps and other useful things.
Press X again while holding R2 and the character will continue searching for traps or other things in the area.
If you are stuck in the adventure, try searching around carefully. You will find an unexpected path.
I've already collected all the treasure, which can be sold, fools.
When I go to...
Do I go to Traps, Senpai?
When I go to Traps, Senpai?
Or do they just show you interactables?
Okay, it looks like they just show you
interactables.
Okay, so these things, they activate.
Okay, okay.
Good.
Oh, okay. So those cards can be interacted with. So, how do I interact with them then?
Do I use...
Sorry.
Give me a moment to get used to the controls and stuff.
Oh, you're so loud!
No?
Okay, well, I'm gonna go over here.
And I'm going to get my bit back.
I'm gonna go this way.
I can hop over that gap to press the switch.
Even with your long legs, I don't think you would make it.
Hampan is a windmouse. When released, he's capable of grabbing items and pressing switches.
Press the square button to release him. Hampan is nimbo and smart,
which allows him to jump over gaps without difficulty.
When Hampan is in motion, use the directional button or left analog stick to control his movements.
Oh, so can Hampan just like...
use the...
Exhaust.
No, you made me tired.
Okay, note to self, we kill this thing first.
Okay.
Well, today was a long day, Senpai.
Actually went out to the optometrist.
Optometrist.
And I got my eye checked again.
Can I just... hold on.
Can I have him go that way?
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Do you get a new prescription? Yeah, I haven't like...
had a prescription since like a decade.
Inertia.
Cost... cost a little quite a bit, but it has to be done since I'm... I'm streaming so much.
A decade, yeah, like over a decade.
Where'd he go? Where's my... where's my little rat man?
Yeah, whatever.
I think, I think it literally only works in certain places.
Oh, dizzy.
Okay, let's see.
Maybe it has to do with these locks things.
Anyways, I have to go in again because the doctor says that they are gonna do more tests on my eye
because they're worried about one of my eyes.
Taking as much one, Senpai.
I'm one under my eye patch they're worried about.
They're worried about that... oh, can I search it? No.
Um, they think that there is a potential that there is damage to the optic nerve.
Actually, balloon first because it's it's easy to kill.
So, it's only one eye that they are very worried about.
Because I was telling...
I was telling the optometrist, the doctor, I was like, oh, I feel like they were like looking at
my eye and they're like, huh, some things are weird with your eye. Like you're getting weird
vision that I don't think is that normal and I will go... I went...
Okay, sorry, this might take a while because brain is not puzzling.
What did you see? I just had trouble. I just kept on saying double, you know?
Like my vision was doubling in one eye. The other eye, not so much.
So, I was like, I was explaining that in one eye,
one eye, it has a doubling effect.
Can I?
I know that I'm supposed to be like, but can I...
Can I like... they said I can control
the direction
of this little guy.
Ah, ah!
I'm trying to do that.
I'm trying to see how to control my little mouse friend.
But it's really funny. It's only in one eye. The other eye is like pretty okay,
but like this eye is not doing so hot.
Was it a hold?
If I need to get surgery for it, when I go back, they'll let me know.
I don't get it. Sorry, I don't get how this little rat thing works.
Ow.
Is there another door somewhere?
Wait, what other door, Senpai?
Senpai?
He can go further if you hit the button.
Okay, it looks like he can only release at certain places.
Can you just fall down?
Well, now I know! I thought I would just hurt him.
When walking off the edge of a road or cliff, the character may pause and appear to be balancing
on the edge. This means the character can jump off, press X while balancing to jump.
If you're dashing, the character will jump without pausing first.
Great. Good to know.
I thought I literally looked like it was not a place you can get to.
We spent so much time together and we're just like doing the prologue.
I'm so sorry, I'm so slow.
I'm so sorry, I'm so slow, Senpai.
Okay. Ow.
Root ass, bitch! I thought you were just a door.
Feel buried. Ow!
They hate me.
What is this?
To lift a box, face the box and press X.
Throw the box, face the target and press X again.
Throw the box to activate switches. Remember, throwing a box will break it in carefully.
Wow, I'm so good at this.
I hope we get to like level six or something real quick.
I'm tired of this bird.
I need a heal berry soon.
Yeah, what happened to my HP, damn?
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Ow, that hurts.
I need the bit crystals now.
Yes, yes, yes. Yes, look at that. We are.
It's funny, it was like we need bit crystals already healed up, leveled up.
You can exhaust me, I have nothing.
Hmm.
Oops.
Was it pressing this button holding X?
All right.
I want to like one, one hit the like birds.
Bird. I want to one hit the birds.
Um, what was the button again to check for, for like,
I said like check for traps and I'm like, aren't these just interactables?
Son of a bitch.
I'll get your ass up.
Bird hate they make.
Oh, shit. Okay, those traps really eat at your, your thing, huh?
They really eat at the, at the health, huh?
Fuck. My bit.
Oh, it's safe.
It's safe. We're alive. They really plan these out quite well, huh?
Can someone do a little research for me?
Uh, one of my supplies, can you do a little research for me?
Is this game on the PlayStation store or is it literally just like a disc?
I know that you can buy like certain games at the PlayStation store.
But I'm not sure if this constitute says one.
And my little feature.
What the hell is this? Spikes? I hate spikes.
Pressing switches simultaneously is easy. That is all for today.
Okay, I'm going to get a box.
Just the original PS1. Okay, so this is a real treat for some pies, huh?
Ha, ha, ha.
Why won't the other Wild Arm games?
Well, I'm so lucky. I feel, I feel very blessed to have this game that's kind of like hard to get.
Let's go. I think just one, two, and three. Okay, so there's still like four and five.
I think there's five, right? Yes.
My bit. Kind of a beach.
Wild Arms 2 is on PSN for PS4 and PS5.
I forgoar.
Open up.
I feel very lucky to share like a very rare game for some pie then.
I wonder why they didn't port this one.
My bit. It's so low.
Fuck.
Was there an item I could carry?
Ah, I literally have to trigger it.
What the fuck?
Remember, you can run.
Just a little bit dumb today. There's so many instructions, okay? I get so confused.
I forgoar. There's so many instructions.
Back again.
It was delayed so many times because of a bug that randomly makes part of the world map disappear.
The bug is still in the game, but if it happens, you just save somewhere normal and restart. Okay.
How much was it delayed for?
Can I just like poke here?
Really?
It's a brand new to you game. Yeah, it's a brand new game to me.
Which is why I'm taking care of all my games. Like they're my precious treasure.
Okay, so. Oh, okay.
Shit. Oh, let me adjust this.
Yes! Okay, okay. Creature. Yes, we did it.
First try.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
It really does look like an SM, the SMT Chorozon.
What level am I now?
I didn't get to see.
I'm a little dummy.
Oh, we're back here again.
Give us a second.
You're at eight.
That's a good level to be at.
Yet I can't one shot hit that stupid bird.
That stupid bird that I hate.
Have you guys seen that video of the guy playing
like Mario Maker?
And then he's at the beginning of the game,
like the title screen.
And he goes, and I hate the stupid bird that I hate.
And then he just listens to him and goes,
the stupid bird that I hate, the stupid bird that I hate.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
That's what I'm just like thinking of right now.
I love that video.
Oh.
I remember an old video, though.
But I feel like no, no one got their reference
when I posted it.
I was surprised that it was real.
So if Sempai's, or some Sempai, that's worse.
Accelerate.
OK, sorry.
If Sempai's know my alt.
There's a post I made that I didn't realize
it was real.
It says over 20 pounds of, and it just reminds me,
there was a video, or it was an audio.
I can't remember.
I was like, the guy literally goes over 20 pounds,
over 20 pounds of, and I was like, oh, yeah, that meme.
And then I went into the store, and I was like, it's so real.
I was surprised that it was actually real.
It looks, I didn't, it was like in the center of the store,
and it was like $700.
I was like, that's a lot of money.
$700, yeah.
I think the store, kind of, what do you call it?
They kind of make the, oh, this is hard.
OK, there we go.
Yeah.
They kind of like, upcharge everything, I guess.
But like, some things were OK priced.
I was like, oh, I didn't know this lot, these stuff were so expensive.
20 pounds, 20 pounds, a pair.
I've seen only, I've only seen like, those things.
They give me a few chances here.
I've only seen it once in a photo where like, someone used it as a vase.
I thought it was entertaining though, because I was like, oh, I remember this like, little voice video clip.
Am I strong enough, I was strong enough to hit it.
I've seen that, right?
We did it, we one tapped the stinking bird.
Stinking bird that I hate.
OK, so that's like a shortcut there.
Stinking bird that I hate, die!
Yeah.
You saddle, I told.
Oh no, the Mario brain rot, huh?
200, Gela.
That's fine.
I was hoping to hear Kauai's Toad voice during the collab.
I didn't do the Toad voice, I just, I don't think I was noticed.
I don't think I was noticed.
I don't think I was noticed, but then again, I was like, oh, whatever.
They give me so much, they're so generous.
They're giving me so much because they know I'm clumsy.
And then I was ruined this.
Oh yee.
Shit.
Don't complain, partner.
Life is often like this.
Let's get down.
Let's get done with this quickly.
Mama mia, it's a spider.
Is that what you wanted?
What?
Check me please, I hate spiders.
Ew!
Ew.
I can't believe I just let that happen!
Ew, don't, don't put your butt at me!
Don't put your butt at me!
What else?
Why are you just standing there?
Literally, you can just move.
I can't believe.
I can't believe you would do that.
Like literally, you could just move!
You can just move.
Hey, you can just move.
I don't understand why you could just move.
Like literally, you could just move.
I'm gonna have to use an item like now.
Why can't it just move?
I don't understand.
I don't understand why you could just move.
Like it's so slow!
Also, this is probably better lag than what people normally do.
I don't like how they just like turn into pollution.
I got nothing!
Give me that.
What the fuck?
Hello?
He?
What the hell is this?
Don't touch anything.
You need to start acting like an adult instead of a child.
You complain too much. Acting like a child is the secret of youth.
Are you just kicking?
Hey, I'm Pan. The person in charge of this ruin is coming.
Huh? That's an owl!
I don't remember the last time we saw one.
What? What's an owl?
You?
Owl?
The owl are a human-chubbed species who existed in Bulgaria long ago.
They were a race, deep in nature, and superior to others in wisdom and magic.
No surprise this ruin was built by you.
So that's Neil, huh?
No. This is just an image of an eel that's being predicted in light by their technology.
This must be an EW era machine used...
No, this is half-pan.
The UI of this kind of reminds me of the PS1 era of SMT games.
Well, we're playing straight up on PS2.
I do have a Devil Summoner and Digital Devil Saga as well.
It's like an elf, but with a W.
Owl?
This must be an LL machine used to transmit information.
They can leave anything to the agents if they leave it in the form of information.
I see Neil now. That's a nice trick to call this place, Ruins of Memo-ing.
Hey, Neil started to say something. No, the voice is speaking inside my head.
The Wild Arms Wiki claims it's pronounced LLU.
Hello? Hello? LLU or LLU? LLU!
No way! The voices!
British Elf.
British Elf? LLU? LLU?
Aw, man. Just like the voices in my head.
Do not wish for Lolithia, whom the LLU have...
Lolithia has freezing breath, freezing palm, the power which can only be used to destroy.
Do not wish for Lolithia, whom the LLU have set in the coffin.
It's blowing snow, storm of death, it's tornado-leading misery, and it's absolute power to destroy everything.
Don't be a little weirdo!
Is it real? Was that an LLU talking? An absolute power to destroy everything.
Hey, Hampan. Where's Lolithia's coffin?
Wait, no. First off, what is Lolithia? You must know.
Don't ask me everything at once, even with my superior wisdom. I don't know everything.
Everything.
What do the voices say? Just like the voices in my head. What do the voices say?
Stop.
Stopping things!
Ah, I see. Well, I'll do for now. Absolute power. I don't think we found a clue to its location.
Ah, that doesn't sound like a good thing.
Yeah, what are you going to do with this absolute power?
Oh, you will see. Either way, I'll have to find it first.
Ah, I don't trust you.
Let's go and look for this Lolithia's coffin.
Can I, like, go in here and just be like, weeee?
It's not. Hello!
I'm blinded by the light. I don't trust this guy.
He looks so disappointed.
I really do think the 3D models they're using is pretty nice.
What? Why does a man search for absolute power? Why? Oh, I don't know.
Maybe to cut the binding change of the past. What will you wish for? Does he believe that absolute power will shine the light on his future?
Why are some of the texts so fast? A man may not realize that absolute power may exactly bind him to his unforgettable past.
Gosh, why is the text so fast?
You're speaking too fast. I cannot catch up.
Go like 3, a girl at a convent. Oh, cute.
He's going to, like, ignore the lightning warning. I don't like Jack so far.
Shaman. Receive my thoughts. Guardian's Shaman.
Are you calling? Where am I?
I don't... I do not know this place, but I feel connected to it.
Can you hear my thoughts, Guardian's Shaman?
Give me your name, then the contract of old will be made once more.
Who are you? Who's calling me? And I'm... not a Shaman.
Hurry, Shaman. Give me your name.
No Gaia will be covered in darkness again. Shaman, give me your name.
My name is Cecilia.
Okay. Cecilia?
Shaman Cecilia. Release my power from the sealed library.
Ah, fuck! Are you always going to do this to me?
Please wait. Who are you? What do you mean by the sealed library?
Cecilia. Oh, Cecilia. Guardian Shaman, Cecilia.
Cecilia. Cecilia. Cecilia. Cecilia?
Hey, Cecilia. You're so absent-minded.
What was I doing? Is that a dream?
On PS1, they called her Innocent One, not just Young Girl.
Why does this game hate eyeballs? Did you all get flashbang too?
Were you daydreaming again? You're almost 17. You shouldn't daydream so much.
You're so strange sometimes. Oh no, she's got chism.
I guess I am strange, but Holly, you're strange too.
Why are you down on your hands and knees like that?
Because I'm checking on you. I'm not the one who's under the table.
Oh, that's true.
Oh god.
Right after the bell, there was an earthquake. You really don't remember?
Yes. I crawled under the desk.
Uh, yeah.
And I heard someone's voice. Whose voice was it calling me a shaman?
Hey, are you daydreaming again?
You don't have time for that. How soon until you return to-
Out of hide.
Time goes by so quickly. You're turning 17, right? You should start telling everyone goodbye.
Goodbye?
If it was not a dream, whose voice was that?
What was that voice trying to tell me? What is this sealed library?
Thank you, Holly. It seems I don't have any time to waste.
Oh.
Ow.
Why did I- I felt that. I really felt that.
I really felt that. I was like, oh.
I'm done with this. I'm done with this.
Oh Cecilia, you're so absent-minded. Are you okay?
It's okay. She's just associating.
I heard your head hit the table and it was so loud. Is your head okay? Let me look at it.
Oh no, you got a huge bump. I'm worried about you.
You're already pretty strange. I hope it doesn't get worse.
I didn't forget to see Sister Mary and Mother Ange, did you? Master Ange, did you?
I know they were always busy, but you should go see them at some point.
The Asian board to the person who took the lamp. Please return it!
Esimism is a feeling. Optimism is a decision.
A telescope is inoperable since it's missing the eyepiece.
I mean the eyepiece then, huh?
There's a globe showing the location of stars and some related magic equipment.
Hang on over here and look at this stuff too.
It's prohibited to use equipment outside of class hours. Dang it!
Oh!
I guess I'll go to this side.
Does that lead outside? What's this?
The stone statue is standing quietly. Quite quietly.
Running hard, running hard.
Kohai, a little, a little dumb.
Oh Cecilia, isn't your departure day near? How are your preparations going? Do you feel ready?
Yes, Sister Mary. Thank you very much for all your kindness.
There is one thing I would like to ask you about.
Cecilia told Mary about the mysterious dream that she had.
Sealed Library, Guardians Shaman. I see you had such a dream.
Sister Mary, what should I do?
A Sealed Library, the voice which told me, called me the Guardians Shaman.
There's so much I don't understand. I'm so confused. Please guide me.
It's easy to go wherever other people might direct you, but you are an adult with so much responsibility.
And so you will have to behave like one.
You have to chart your own course and then face whatever may happen along the way.
For this reason, Cecilia, I will not give you any advice in regards to this revelation.
You will be fine, Cecilia.
There's nothing you cannot overcome. Just remember that all you learned at the Quran Abbey.
Our world, Fogaya, its title caught your attention while you read it.
More than 1,000 years ago, Fogaya was torn apart by a battle when alien invaders from another world.
All the inhabitants of Fogaya, humans, aloo and guardians,
one by banding together and using their combined might.
But the price of victory came at a horrible cost.
Aliens!
Aliens.
Now you can't hunt aliens!
You've got to use them. You've got to be real tricky.
I feel like every game we've been playing has some sort of aliens.
The world could not sustain itself without the support of the now powerless guardians.
It was certain that gradually Fogaya would become a dry, desolate wasteland.
Today, no one has devised a way to stop the inevitable destruction of our world.
Alright.
Nice bed.
Oh, that's a window.
Sister, have you been drinking?
Sister, sister, sister. No better.
That earthquake was such a shock.
At first I thought I was convulsing and that's why everything was shaking.
Then I realized that my cup on the table was shaking too.
I was so surprised I almost screamed.
That girl.
Cecilia, do you mind if I tell you something?
I was arranging the books and noticed that a book that should be here is missing.
I'm irritated since it does not look good to only have the first volume of a series.
Look at me wrong. It has nothing to do with me caring about how the story ends.
Anyway, if you find the next volume somewhere, will you mind bringing it back?
Ooh, I got an event.
We're arranging books now. Here, take a look at this, Cecilia.
The magic book, Della Metallica.
Della Metallica is placed in children's literature next to Tragedy of Dolly.
I feel unhappy more than angry.
I wonder if other people feel strange when they see books placed in the wrong genre or not in alphabetical order.
Here.
Crest you, sir.
This title caught your attention. Will you read it?
An expert is able to understand a crest and use the power from it.
It's called a crest sorcerer.
If the expert is a female, she's called a crest sorceress.
Also, yes, I do feel irritated when like things are not in order.
Basic crest sorcery.
The technique of constructing magic by combining two crests is known as crest sorcery.
These crests enable users to cast magic without performing a large ceremony as modern style of magic dynamics.
Did I do basic yet?
Oh, I did it.
Recommend magic, yeah.
When you don't have that many crests, Grah,
make sure one of them is for HP restoring magic.
For there's life, there's hope.
It's find a way out of any difficulty by staying alive under any circumstances.
There are many useful attack magic spells as well.
We recommend learning fire magic.
Fire elemental magic is the most popular obstructive magic and will not, will often prove effective.
It is useful against most elemental base creatures except for light elemental monsters and undead monsters.
I think I really recommended magic, right?
Della Metallica.
Oh, Aimee.
Thank you for the raid, Aimee.
You'd romance the aliens? Yeah.
Hello, hello, Aimee. Welcome to the stream.
How's stream? Good, we're still on the prologue, but I'm reading.
I'm reading a lot. Welcome raiders, welcome to the stream.
Welcome everyone, hello.
I'm sure you know me, but my name is MercyModease from Vialorgen1 in Dolj.
I am currently playing Wild Arms Ultra Code F on the PS2.
I am literally playing it on original hardware and this is a, this is a disc.
I am playing the game, I am playing the physical copy of the game.
And I am capturing it through a retro take and game capture.
So please enjoy. Apparently this game has not been ported anywhere.
And so you can only play this game on original hardware. Yes.
This is apparently a pretty rare game.
So please enjoy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
oh, oh oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh holy crap it makes sense
Wait, we're still in the prologue?
I think we go through like all the characters, prologues first?
Thank you for sharing.
I will relax and watch.
Thank you, I mean please just relax, thank you, and I want all my supplies to relax
and newcomers as well, thank you.
Many ancient techniques are considered forbidden territory in today's world, for example planting
life into metal.
If an unskilled sorcerer gained this book, the world's natural order could be overturned.
For that reason, I sealed this book.
If you'd like to release the seal, tame the key of knowledge, then the essence of this
magic book will be revealed.
I think that's the same one, Della Metallica.
The challenge of magic, let's go.
It's illegal to impregnate robots in this world?
You're right, it is!
Don't be a fail, afloat, afloat, afloat, afloat, afloat, afloat, afloat, afloat, afloat!
If you construct magic by mistake, you can just disassemble it.
The thing you should fear is clinging to magic you constructed.
Searching for new power, depending on the battle and the situation is best, have style
and try different magic.
Hold on, I'm going to just turn this she-you-round.
Elemental properties, yeah, we'll read this one.
Elemental properties classify the energy, flow, and characteristics of attack type magic
as follows.
Earth, water, fire, wind, ice, thunder, light, darkness, hate property classes.
The relation of those classes are earth, wind, water, and thunder, fire and ice, light, and
darkness.
So when using wind against earth or ice against fire, expect better results.
There is attack magic that is pure energy and does not belong in any class.
These are known as non-elementals.
Alright, anything else, can I look at books, no, no, no, no, no other books, no books!
Ooh, it's spin pretty badly so I don't like it.
Well, let's be on the test, it better not be.
The well is so deep that you can't see the bottom, there's only sweet smell of fresh
water.
Is that is what the device is on, which prevents the door from being opened.
Did you call the smell of water sweet?
Who are we playing as right now, girl named Cecilia.
There is attack type and support type magic, let me explain the effect of each.
Attack magic changes molecular movement, support magic changes molecular structure,
messages.
All different magic you can use are made by combining any two crests.
There are four types, geo, fray, wing, and muse, is that difficult to follow?
Anyway, you practice by creating spell.
Learning through trial and error is best.
Key.
Below the large picture is a plaque, the portrait of the founder.
There's so much doors, what's behind door number one?
I'm not that good at magic, but I am the most talented musician at this abbey, what
kind of music should I play today?
F type one.
Oh, it's a playlist.
Key person.
Crest graph, is it the same one?
Crest graph is a small square stone which can be imbued with magical powers.
There are four crest types.
Crest sorcerers infuse a crest graph, the primary and secondary graph, crest, and the
two fused to form a distinct spell.
Oh my gosh, suddenly I got so hot senpai.
I'm melting, melting.
I think I have water with me.
Oh no, I'm going to turn off some lights, maybe it's just, maybe I'm just overheating
a little.
In this fashion, sorcerers can easily carry magic with them for personal use.
With all the possible combination of crests, there are a total of 32 different kinds of
magic spell available to crest sorcerers.
Okay.
I wonder if the accepted will open the closet without permission.
Can I open it?
I don't have talent in terms of magic, though the Zed class the other day was fun.
I hit my partner with my scepter, my scepter I was covered in empty points, so the old
saying goes better to carry a cane than to fall down.
When MP is about to run out, you get an idea to recover MP by using your scepter.
I want to open it without permission, really bad.
I want to open it without permission.
Why do you need permission?
Inherited tears.
Okay.
A small shiny blue Pryoxy, Blue Archive, Blue Archive, I can't escape.
No, not the Blue Archive brain wrong.
It's like Pryoxy, not you again.
They knew even in 2005 that is passed down through Outer Hyde Royalty, shaped like a
teardrop, it fits in the palm of one's hand, it's priceless, it blinks repeatedly with
a fixed rhythm, like that of a heartbeat, heart beating.
The teardrop is passed down from generation to generation, through the females of the Outer
Hyde Royal family.
Okay.
So we're getting some lore.
Literal brain rot.
Am I right guys?
Am I right Senpai, literal brain rot happening.
Belief of Guardians, this title caught your attention, would you like to read it?
Though the Guardians have lost their power, it is rumored they once held Fogaya together
and still exist in this world.
If we regard them as mere superstition, the Guardians power is the essence of life of
Fogaya.
This is the belief of those that praise the Guardians, and it is the belief taught here
at Koran, Abbey, pray to the Guardians, Earth Dragons, Earth Dragon, Rude Div, Water Turtle,
Skirt, Skirt Too Dark, Skirt Too Dark, Firebird, Morgalt, and Wind Tiger, Algalon, pray to them
and always appreciate life.
These are names.
I want to go in your closet without permission.
Let me talk.
Hello Cecilia.
You have good timing, I just finished the Ley Line device.
Device measure, the Guardians power flowing through Fogaya.
I should be able to observe the whole planet if it works as planned, it not only supports
my study about Guardians, but it might solve the mystery of Fogaya's deterioration and
reverse the process.
Reverse Fogaya's deterioration, that happens many lives would be saved.
I will pray for the Ley Line device to help you with this.
But Master Ange, what do you mean by good timing?
Oh, it's related to the teardrop that you possess.
I heard Sister Mary say the teardrop is a family heirling that connects girls in the
Adahide royal family to Guardians.
I'd like you to observe the Ley Line device while you use the teardrop to connect with
the Guardians mind.
If you are successful in connecting, it might affect the Ley Line.
This device observes a reaction to the connection of you and a Guardian.
It will confirm that my device works.
Master Ange, I've never heard of anyone actually communicating Guardians just by
viewing the teardrop.
I don't think I can meet your expectations.
Even if you fail, can you please try?
I don't mind if it doesn't work.
If it does, I'd like to see if it affects the Ley Line.
Understand, Master Ange, I won't give it a try.
During an adventure, you need to use specific items to trigger an event.
To use an event item, open your inventory and select items.
In the item menu, press R1 until you are on the event item spray page.
Select the item you would like to use and press X.
Note, you can only use the event item in specific locations.
So like...
Okay, so is this the item?
Okay, hold on.
First, I want to show...
Can I be used here to hang it?
I'm like, Kenneth, do you have this?
Not again.
Shaman Cecilia, concentrate on the teardrop.
In the sealed library, release me from the book of Nelgau.
By your shaman's blood of royal descent, as one who inherits the teardrop, release me.
The teardrop of voice is sent directly into my heart.
At the sealed library, release me.
Are you... please tell me, what can I do?
What does the teardrop do?
Cecilia, what happens to Cecilia?
Oh, it's alright, you're awake now.
First I thought you had started a daydream and then I was worried, then I realized you weren't.
Maybe I shouldn't have asked you to do this.
I'm okay, but I felt like, with the help of the teardrop, I was able to sense this mysterious voice.
Teardrop?
All of the teardrop causes the leyline observation machine to react.
Perhaps the teardrop you wear is tied to the leyline origins.
A voice you heard may be a guardian.
The machine observes the leylines.
In other words, this device may be able to sense the power of the guardians.
Anyway, it appears I was correct with my little experiment.
Thank you for operating.
I wonder if the...
Clearly they're supposed to be like the...
Like a...
Biackel...
What are the other guys called again?
Target tool is an item that automatically highlights important objects around in yellow.
In the party menu, you can turn the effect on or off by selecting the target tool and using it.
So I can just use it?
The four bees? Yeah, the divine...
Vist.
Wait...
How'd I use the target tool again?
Yeah.
They had to use it again.
Yeah, they have the same elements.
Yeah, then it would be the bees and the guardians.
It's a square? I'm pressing square. I don't think it's square.
Unless it's like holding this down and looking around again, like...
I don't know.
Hill?
Press the select button, koai. Okay.
Should be right. Maybe there's nothing to interact with.
This makes me go.
She moves.
I'm pressing the select button. I don't think anything's happening.
Don't run in the hallway. It's prohibited. If you were caught, you will sit in the corner.
See, it's library. I heard about it, but it's not a scoop.
I heard it's one of current Abbey's seven wonderful secrets.
Memory's certain, right? The story is.
Stand before the holy woman who guards the door and raise the light of light, then the way will be opened.
But the story's a lie.
You're a lamp at the holy woman statue and it didn't show any reaction.
You're with a different sort of life.
You're the one that stole the lamp!
Party menu.
Party?
She's cute though.
Look bad!
So, it highlights objects you can interact with if you had to turn on, but how do I turn it on?
Senpai, how do I turn it on?
Also for coins, yeah, let's open it.
In ancient times, Gimmel coins were a currency of El, Elu.
The coin have retained remnants of their magical heritage.
Use them at any time to save your game to your memory card.
Yes, too.
If you are defeated during battle, your Gimmel coins also function as continues.
However, your experience points for the next level up will be lost and the number of continues you use are recorded.
Make sure you use your Gimmel coins carefully.
How do I turn it on in my inventory?
Sorry!
Just like the instruction was like...
Oh, I can save here.
I saw a yellow...
Oh, like this.
Oh! Okay, I see it now.
So, so, so.
There we go.
Okay, so it's just, you just have to like walk by it.
Okay, it was so not visible in the other areas.
The very existence of the legendary Elu is all but forgotten to the sands of time.
Elu are similar to humans in appearance except they have long ears and are covered with fur.
Okay, they're not elves! Elves! Furry! They're furry elves!
The only evidence we have of their existence comes from folklore and a few eyewitness accounts.
Why did the Elu who possessed such power disappear from Gaia?
There are many theories, but the mystery remains unsolved.
It seems the truth has died with the Elu.
I'm the gardener's graze! Would you like to see my child?
I refuse to believe that this bird is like eloquent in any way.
I think the Elu are extinct, yes.
You have some fried up chow mein. Try this since you are here.
You ate the chow mein. It was such gusto.
You ate the chow mein with such gusto.
I love it when people enjoy the food I made. Come back any time you're hungry.
I would love food. Oh, there's a person here.
Hey, you know what I heard?
Sister Mary was the classmate of Cecilia's mother at the party.
Both her beautiful and best friends. They were really mischievous.
It always caused trouble in the abbey. It's hard to imagine Sister Mary like that.
Does this mean that being mischievous when you're young will lead to youthful discretion at Sister Mary's age?
Me? I wish for such youthful mischievousness.
Okay, uh, dizzy.
Okay, Uncle Logan. Uncle Logan's noodles are world-famous.
Whenever you are tired, come over and have some chow mein.
Everything like your HP, MP and V at the gauges are refilled instantly.
And all negative statuses affect are removed.
I don't think this is the end.
Send for a chow mein.
But, now it is!
Mama Mia, but Maya chow mein is the only way for you to recover.
Whenever you level up from your bath or experience your whole body recovers, so keep leveling
up.
It's like I'm eating Uncle Logan's chow mein!
It is probably not how this should go.
Our fagaya.
I think I read this right?
Yes, we've read it.
Of course it's a great name for an Italian chef!
This one?
Okay, we can't leave!
So what do I do with this witch book?
Maybe I do have to use it on her or something.
Now with that book, may I take a look at it?
And the book of Trish.
You are read to you now.
If you get tired, let me know by pressing the star button.
The dull sound of my footsteps echoed off the floor.
I was all alone.
I removed my helmet and shook my head.
I was in the graveyard of the pillar people.
It was the best location for the experiment.
Still, I was scared that I had brought the high-density energy crystal here.
After removing my firearm, I sat on a half-broken stone bench.
Experiment.
Using an energy crystal as a catalyst to power the space-time warp to 536 revolutions before,
was this a way to end the war?
I rested on the stone and closed my eyes.
The face of the girl that I killed three days ago floated before my eye.
What had a civilian been doing here?
She had approached me and placed her hand in her pocket.
I thought she was the enemy, and so I had thrust my sword without hesitation.
But she had been defenseless.
No weapons on her at all.
I sighed deeply and examined the communication device that had laying next to the crystal.
When I flipped the power switch on, the radio told me to pray.
I bit my tongue and turned it off.
For a moment, the green splay illuminated the movements of insects.
336 revolutions ago.
In those days, God supposedly insisted prayers had purpose.
But the gods had disappeared somewhere along the way,
and now we spent our time fighting battles and holding our hands over our hearts in useless prayer.
The gods we worship had disappeared, so why couldn't people stop praying?
People were still looking for someone to help us and give our sins, but gods didn't exist anymore.
I rubbed the hilt of my sword and exhaled, used to pray.
I stood up, but before I started roaming around, the ruins.
I paused to examine the energy crystal.
Out of the corner of my eye, I noticed a cross-shaped star rise above the trees.
Almost immediately, a blinding white light jumped out of the crystal and engulfed my body.
The world went white upon impact, and a strangled yell was forced for my throat.
My internal organs felt as if they were being crushed.
I tried to let go of the crystal.
As the pain slowly faded, I felt like I was left floating in an inky black darkness.
My lips trembled. My senses were locked in.
Ah, claustrophobic terror. There we go.
What was happening? Was I dying?
I almost went crazy at the utter blackness.
When an orange light engulfed my shoulders, the crystal was collapsing.
It dissolved a small particle like a fine powder, which floated off into the deep black darkness.
I calmed down a little.
The crystal's sudden splintering seemed logical, and for some strange reason, I was sure this was all real and not a dream.
I felt my body float off in the same direction the lights were floating.
I couldn't say I knew where I was going, but compared to staying where I was in the darkness,
it seemed the better option.
All I could do now was pray that I reached some place of safety.
Pray? Me?
I took a deep breath and exhaled through my nose.
I devoted all of my thoughts to prayer, though I felt I could not expect salvation,
and suddenly, without a surge of hope, I, who never believed in prayer,
I couldn't... I could feel myself moving faster, though I couldn't actually sense my body.
Had I been vaporized by the orange light like the crystal,
I struggled with the idea of having no body.
Was I just a floating spirit? Thankfully, I lost consciousness.
I could feel a slight warmth on my cheek, and I regained consciousness.
Shine? I felt a difference. Suddenly, I could feel my body again.
Even my ears were tickling. They'd fallen asleep.
I moved my numb fingers and tried to touch my cheek.
I heard someone gasp, a slight rustling noise.
When I opened my eyes, I felt like someone was continuously hitting my head.
First thing I saw was the warm orange light,
the bright stained glass window, which scattered them by the sunshine.
Then pale, slender hands, I narrowed my eyes with slender hands for blurry, orange light.
There's pictures!
The warm light twinkled and disappeared like magic.
I blinked, looked upwards, and found eyes that were blue like the southern sea, staring into my home.
Do you feel any pain?
Ruby lips, red lips, framed to the question.
Lustrous hair fringed her small pale face.
N-no.
Sorry.
My voice croaked out of a parched throat.
She seemed around my own age, 17 or so.
Her face gave off a strange impression, a mix of precociousness and childlike naivety radiating equally.
While I was wondering if I should have spoken to her more politely, I started around, trying to see everything.
While I was wondering if I should have spoken to her more,
wait, fuck, I read that part.
Her fingers were spotted with fragments of colorful light.
I could feel the coldness of the stone building, the ceiling yawned high above the chapel.
Colored dance in the stained glass behind her.
She looked at my eyes and said,
Pain canary.
The world without gods and waiting for you.
Pain canary?
Her voice was low and gentle.
I looked away and watched into my lens.
I noticed that the crystal was gone.
I could feel the sweat on my palm.
Something sparked in my brain.
A space-time experiment.
Did it work?
Pain canary, write it down, write it down, write it down!
I realized she was still waiting for a response.
Her head cocked to the side and I swallowed, opened my mouth.
Please, please tell me where this place is and what your name is.
She smiled softly and nodded.
This place is 536 revolutions before your world, a place still protected by gods.
The law of your world differs from those that rule our life.
She spoke, she combed my hair back, placed her hand on my forehead.
This is the light of god, of the god of life.
The magic which dwells in my blood.
Her eyes closed and she chanted.
At the same moment she finished, warm light engulfed me again.
Magic?
Hey, magic, I whispered.
Gods exist in this world?
Yes, I cannot imagine a world where they do not exist.
She smiles and her blue eyes looked over me.
She reached out her hand to me.
I did not understand her smile.
Welcome to this period, Cain.
My name is Laurie.
I'm a rulekeeper.
I serve the god of time and life.
I took her hand in mine.
I wondered how long I had lain on her lap.
Before I could ask, she looked up, lifted her head slightly and bit her tongue.
But she noticed something.
I still need rest.
The air was chilly like a winter morning, but a strange sensation I never felt before.
Laurie looked down on me.
She smiled softly.
It's okay.
I will protect you.
I... I was bored.
Laurie stood up before I could ask her what she meant.
And with me, he rushed to the exit of the chapel and pushed open the thick wooden door.
Because it looked very heavy, I went next to her to help.
I noticed her body so rigid.
Matter.
As soon as I asked her, a white flashing light shined through the stained glass window.
It's too early.
Laurie frowned at her lip as she turned around.
Cain, come with me.
I have to protect this world.
So I need your cooperation to do so.
I need you to go to Passover Festival.
It will be held in the capital ten days from now.
Eyes held mine with urgency.
But people who would disturb it exist.
What do you mean?
Who are you?
I asked for an explanation, but Laurie was not listening to me.
An explosion occurred at close range.
I covered my head at once and tried to plant my feet.
But I was thrown back inside the chapel.
I groaned as I hit my hip against something.
In my blurred view, I looked for Laurie.
Her movement switched smoothly from a defensive stance to a fighting one.
I stood and drew my sword hurriedly.
The scattered rubble and dust, I could only hear mine and Laurie's breath.
We moved close together and looked around.
There was no one around.
Suddenly the hairs on the back of my neck grizzled, warning me I was wrong.
A mild early summer sunlight danced merrily on the plain wooden floor.
But in the quiet room, something was out of place.
Laurie stood there back to mine.
I can't believe it.
I slowly followed her view to the altar.
For nobody existed seconds ago, a silver-haired girl in black now stood.
For some reason her face sent shivers down my spine.
Rule breaker, it's too early.
You pay no attention to Laurie.
A beautiful girl smiled at me.
Her smile was bloody and sinister.
All I could do was tremble.
Oh, what?
Oh, okay, let's stop here.
These books are really good!
Damn!
It's over!
Do we have more?
Right?
We need to find the rest!
What the hell?
Where's the goddess statue again?
This one.
Statue of a holy woman circled by the other statues as if being guarded in the face of the west.
Is that it?
Yeah.
We have to show it the light of light.
Is it our teardrop?
Ooh!
What is she looking at?
Does it say keep off the grass? I would laugh.
No rough housing on the lawn!
Isn't this like...
What do you call it?
Isn't this um...
The Zelda game?
Breath of the Wild?
The carving of a mysterious pattern looks like the teardrop.
I got this.
It's always the light!
Sealed library.
Oh no! It took that long for me to get to the actual prologue thing.
Oh shit!
I'm finding books?
Man! I'm weak as hell! You're right! I need to use my magic! What the hell?
Fire.
Burn the book! Oh god!
Oh, we're anchoring people burning.
Got tinder staff.
The tinder staff is a magic staff that emits fire when the button, the B button, no, the square button is pressed.
You can light torches and melt ice by using the staff.
You can throw the direction of the fire using the directional button or left analog stick while holding the down button.
Like this.
When the candlestick burns, the door will be open.
Candlestick.
These guys?
They're lighting up.
Guys, I'm kind of dumb.
Oh!
Like, yeah, having a...
Uh, I'm trying to...
Can I move up?
This direction's right.
Oh!
Oh, maybe it does reach from the top of the stairs.
I'll go check.
Yeah, fuck these books.
Oh!
Maybe that candle?
Wow, I feel deceived!
I feel fucking deceived!
Ah!
Oh!
Hahaha!
Oh, sorry, not that.
Is that an urchin?
It might be.
I hear urchins are delicious.
I want to try.
Okay, well, there's places to go.
On the side.
Oh!
Vip, vip, vip!
Goodbye, you little shit.
Have you had sushi?
Mercy, it's like one of my favorite foods, but, um...
I've never had urchin before.
I mostly have, like, you know, like the cheap, um...
...fishes?
Like, uh, salmon, tuna...
What's the other side to?
This map's huge!
What the hell?
The fuck?
This map is huge!
Oh!
Oh, yeah, I've had doonagi!
I have...
Oh!
Yeah, thanks, but I'm just not...
I'm just like, I don't think I've had urchin before.
I even had inari sushi, which is, like, just like tofu.
By the way, it's delicious.
Oh, I always forget, sorry.
Uh, and I also like, um...
I like, kind of like, you know, like the mac-y rolls.
They're like cucumber and stuff.
I like those two.
I'm like, these are very big rules.
I don't even know which way I'm supposed to go, senpai.
Should I go down first, or should I go...
Left?
Sorry, right?
Maybe I should go down first?
No, check the upper levels, okay.
Maybe they see on this library, because people kept on getting lost.
Yeah, me, okay, it's a pillbug.
It does not look like a pillbug.
Ew, horny.
I mean...
Fun fact, California rolls...
A chef in Vancouver says he invented them.
Oh, okay.
I, personally, I don't think I can eat California rolls.
What's in a California roll again?
If, um...
I think I can eat them.
Not fish eggs.
It's California roll, um...
The one with imitation crab.
Because imitation crab is definitely something that I cannot...
The sword guardian blade is named Tainted...
I guess the heart was sent this far on the earth.
There's egg and imitation crab?
Yeah, it's made with egg.
That's why I always, when a place goes, yeah, we serve crab.
I'm like, it's an imitation crab, because I cannot have that.
I like crab, but like, imitation crab is danger.
It's danger, and I feel...
I feel sad, because I'm like, oh!
Never knew imitation crab with egg.
Yeah, it's like, oh, eggs.
The more you know, Senpai!
Why is there so freaking much?
How far down does this go?
I found it out when I was eating crab.
We were eating imitation crab with my friend,
because she got like a whole bunch of imitation crab,
and then I had to go to the hospital!
Then we found out imitation crab has eggs!
Great.
How do I... oh, it's so hard.
Worst way to find out, oh yeah, oh yeah.
That's it.
Also, no ramen, right?
It depends on the ramen.
It really depends on the ramen.
So, the ramen...
There are some ramen I can have.
Instant ramen?
Yeah, that's fine.
Meaghan ramen, also fine.
It really depends.
I just have to ask what kind of like...
What kind of ramen noodles are you using?
Donkotsu ramen is no good.
Really, I have to do it all over again?
Oops, nearly fell and died again.
I don't know what to do.
Oops.
Ah, come on, really?
Not heal, sorry.
Ah!
They're so evil.
Seriously?
Ah!
Which one went out?
I know I can skip battles.
I know.
I just forgot how.
Ah!
I hate the angle it's in too.
Game is stupid and it hates me.
Oh my god!
It's a bitch.
It hit me twice.
Ah!
What?
They were on at the same time, what the hell?
Ah!
Can I not fall, thank you?
Maybe there has to be an order too?
There's a sign around here?
Fuck.
Let me just go back here.
Of course there's a sign.
Light up the ends, light up the center,
but only three then you may enter.
I hit the wrong one!
Shut up.
Oh!
Ah!
Go out already.
That is...
That's actually so mean.
Fuck!
It's the angles that are really hard.
Sorry, senpai.
I'm kind of stupid.
I keep on hitting the two of them.
I have to go like this.
I'm going to go like this.
Come on.
It's really unfair of the timing.
If I do it sideways,
maybe it will work.
No.
It does not work.
Ah!
It's so fucking hard to...
Where the fuck are you looking at?
Come on.
Damn.
I'm actually kind of sick of this puzzle.
It's the aiming?
That was so bad.
The aiming was the hard part, senpai.
It's not...
This is not easy.
I don't believe...
See, I end up aiming there
because she doesn't do good.
See?
I can't skip battles anymore.
This is going to be hell.
Ah!
Fucking idiot.
Okay.
Okay, I can't...
I can't do it anymore.
Okay.
Does it not work if you shoot them straight on?
Because I...
If I shoot them straight on,
they hit...
They don't hit them all the time.
You son of a bitch!
My death perception, bad.
I ain't want to kill this game.
I want to kill this game.
Fuck!
We're able to skip these battles.
At least they don't hurt me anymore
because I'm too high level.
I'm just mad now.
I'm just mad.
Just mad.
I swear.
I swear if someone's going like...
Like, please be patient with me, Senpai.
Please be patient with me.
Move faster.
You have to be so quick with it.
I hate how fast you have to be with it.
I hate it. I hate it. I hate it.
Ugh.
We hate books.
Just kidding. I love books.
But not these ones!
That was not a well-designed puzzle.
Mostly because of the timing.
I feel like...
If they just lowered the enemy encounter rate there,
it would have been easier.
Alright.
High fires with short lives.
By standing at its peak, give life.
Then the door shall be opened.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, they're so...
Warcry.
How big is this freaking map?
The music's good, yeah?
The music's pretty good.
I'm just... I'm just mad.
I'm just mad now.
I'm so clumpy.
I'm so clumpy, Senpai.
Meow.
I'm so clumpy!
I think that puzzle really sucked because of the encounter rate.
The encounter rate for that area I felt like was pretty high.
The tear drop faintly shimmers as your eyes glaze the stone statue.
Nice.
Honestly, I think if they lowered the encounter rate for that one area,
that would have been better.
But for some reason, the encounter rate in that area seems...
Quite high?
You know?
Going on here.
Oh!
Press and hold X in front of the wheel to make the character grab the real rotate.
Left analog stick to make the character off the...
This?
Oh!
I literally have to use it like a wheel.
Okay, actually that's kind of hard.
That's really hard!
Oh!
Fuck. I can't fucking see.
I took a while to see what it meant.
And you will claim.
It just... You have to spin it several times before it can...
Before the wheel can like...
Before it can actually move.
It's kind of annoying.
Okay.
Because I didn't know if it was working.
It just felt like it wasn't working, you know?
Okay.
But like, I legitimately thought it wasn't working.
Okay, so...
All you have to do.
Now...
I can climb all the way up here.
Stay in a second!
This is where I started!
Bye-bye!
Thank you for the...
I don't know what A is.
Thank you for the... Is that Australian?
Oh! Super Cat! Hi! Hi! Game's Drop!
Where was I supposed to go then?
Wait, was there...
Oh, shit. Sorry.
There like, some place over...
Oh!
It's Australian! Okay!
She's only level 4! That's surprising!
There's like, other rooms here now.
Wait.
Did I go here already?
Ready?
Memory shot!
Was I there already?
Sorry!
I feel like my memory is like, gone.
Oh! I think I know where we are now.
She moved so fast.
Oh!
Memory no good!
Just like me, for real, for real.
Oh, I see. It's a completely different room up here.
It's good.
What does this do?
I'm gonna put this to the center again.
I don't know.
Bye bye!
Is this not what I'm doing right now?
Okay, okay. Settle down, chat.
Life on this planet.
Yeah, I'll just fight it.
Blue Book. I love how it's just called Blue Book!
Oh!
Gradual.
Because I can't.
I can't.
Senpai! Senpai!
Thank you for the two super chat.
Is that all?
I just wanted to hear the senpai.
FX again.
Yay!
Okie dokie!
I like reading books.
Book of Genesis.
This is the story of the Elu Sword.
A blacksmith forged the sword from living metal.
It was forged to open the world's future,
as it was in the beginning, so be it in the end.
This is the blade that defends the dark
and slays their asses.
The sword was named Guardian Blade.
It is imbued with the power to save worlds.
Lost Guardian.
The guardian lord who ruled all life,
the lord of the four guardians
who ruled the basis of all creation.
They were not bound to the past, the power of pain.
Guardians who fed courage,
the courage to live in the present,
the power to shield the mind.
Guardians who fueled love,
desire for the future,
the belief that dreams do come true.
Guardians who ruled hope,
the light that once lived in everyone's hearts.
Courage, love, and hope are lost in time.
Even their meanings have been long forgotten.
Aw.
Properties and its meaning.
The guiding principle of a Crest Sorcerer
is to know the weakness of an enemy.
I'm an enemy!
For example, the creature Nelgal
is charged with the power of fire.
So one who possesses water and ice
is an enemy.
This is Nemesis.
Nemesis!
Wow, I am like biting my tongue
all the time.
I'm biting my tongue as I'm like speaking.
Yeah.
During the battle, vulnerability is very important,
especially for a Crest Sorcerer.
Use the elements to affect the battle.
I must know the enemy and their weakness.
This is the first step towards victory over an opponent.
Okay, let's see what this...
Move fast!
Thank you.
I'm the...
Sorry, Omegaverse mansion!
I am the Alpha and Omega, past and future united.
The future is made by my edge.
Speak my name and remember the lonesome history.
It was Guardian Blade, right?
I felt Guardian again.
A...
R...
B...
A...
I...
N...
How do I do a space?
Like this?
Oh, yeah!
Blood...
Blade...
A...
C...
That...
Oh, it fits!
So, I hope it is.
I can use both sides, right?
It doesn't matter.
It looks like it just goes in one circle.
Oh, at least that did nothing to me!
It sounded scary, but it did nothing!
Okay, I'm putting my eyepatch back on.
Sorry, I needed to concentrate!
I...
I call this high-five!
I usually sit on my desk,
just to catch back on...
Sorry.
I needed to concentrate!
Oh!
I look cooler with my- I look so cool though, Zempai.
Wait, was there more books I could look at?
I want to read the books!
Oh, there were- there were more, and I'm just seeing it now, what the heck?
Fall off.
Stand Into World is a title that caught your eye, would you like to read it?
Yes.
A world outside of the Ring of Order represents a world without harmony.
It's certainly- it will certainly face destruction.
Before we face the coming end, we the aloo abandon this world and leave it- leave it
to its future doom.
We exist within the life force of this world, so when the world ends, so do we.
Peer far into the distance, and we shall be no more.
Hey what?
You- you- you laughed?
Did you just like, aww, you know?
Do.
First wanderer.
Neither monsters, snare, nor dust storms bite can take the wings from the wanderer's
flight.
In Fugaya, adventures are called wanderers.
Some prefer to call them dream chasers, migrants, drifters, or mercs.
The aloo's- aloo's are doomers, yeah, yeah they are.
They are like migrating birds moving from one place to another, nomads.
folklore and writings tell us that among the first wanderers was a character named Alan
Smithy.
Alan Smithy's legend is steeped in mystery.
In fact, recent studies suggest that it is doubtful that such a character ever existed.
It also just suggested the name Alan Smithy is only a euphemism to describe the moral
and values of the wanderer culture.
Although there was ever a real man named Alan Smithy, we don't ever know, perfect.
Wait, if it runs away I have no EXP, that's so rude.
Well I don't have enough MP, so I have to hit it.
I was hoping she would level up already, but she didn't.
Give me my MPs back.
I need 6 MP, that sucks, at least, at least they die, and I literally take no health.
This might take a while, sorry Senpai, do you have any items or skills to restore MP?
I have no idea.
I just kind of want to hit them.
I'll look at the item list soon.
I just want her, I just want Cecilia to level up quickly so that she can just get it.
Yeah, see, we got all our MPs back.
See, we got it Senpai, we did it.
We have book, it's a book, infinite sequence systems.
The reason time has no end is that new time is constantly being created by a machine.
Some people believe a guardian rules time and call it the infinite sequence system,
or perpetual engine.
That is a new one, like a machine creating time, a person standing on the altar of time
can control time as they please.
What do people hope to accomplish by controlling time, changing the past, creating a new future
I do not know.
Garden Fagalia
There are some Fagalia guardians legends, some guardians exist only in folklore, but
some are real.
Guardians ruled Fagalia.
I do not know what they look like, their powers are even their names, secret mysterious
guardians.
Koran doctrine tells us that these guardians, not spoken of in folklore of heretics, hold
the key to regenerating this planet.
Who is this being?
Alright, let's go.
Is this the book of dead?
Book of Nogaw, and the book, when this book was written, seems to be about an old monster
who was born from magic and consumes magical powers, Nogaw.
The skin book, yeah.
Are you seeking wisdom for power, or are you the one who heard the whisper of water?
No matter which you are, read this as a book written by dark forces, everything is now
Nogaw's flushing blood.
This looks like a dojin material.
As a human being, you radiate magical power.
Nogaw deems you worthy for consumption.
Am I wrong?
Am I wrong, though?
You're the voice that's been calling me?
No, I only have sinister thoughts from you.
Hear the water whispering, convince me of your power if you are the shaman.
The whisper of water?
Shaman?
If you would like to hear the voice, you should defeat me and see.
The whisper of water is there.
No effect, shit.
Scoop up!
No!
Oh wait, it's not too bad.
Damn!
If it has no effect on him, what do I do?
Do you spell on me?
Maybe on him?
Wait, why is there, like, many of you?
Come in Cecilia, listen to me, release Guardian's power.
Obtained medium?
Oh, was it?
Cecilia, forceability, and material manifest Guardian powers temporarily by consuming F.P.
Depending on which elemental medium you select, consume F.P. and the effects of the power are
different.
For example, the water guardian, Scroogeardark.
Scroogeardark?
Attacks all enemies with water, give me a try.
Ooh, pretty.
Oh, that's a lot of stuff.
Damn.
Aw, no.
What is this name?
Scroogeardark.
Long ago, I was captured and imprisoned in a book by Nelgau's magical power.
Shaman, I have longed for you to listen to my whisper.
Shaman.
Shaman, why do you call me Shaman?
You are the one who understands our spirit and can change your spirit to power.
Shaman, inheritor of the teardrop.
After this long period of time, Gogaia is about to be enveloped in darkness.
Shaman, can you hear it in your mind?
The sorrow of the sky and ocean, the anger of earth and wind.
Yes, I can hear, I can hear, I can feel the teardrop connecting me to those voices.
Shaman, unite us.
Use our power to fight the Stio Menace, which threatens all life on this world.
The battle for sky and earth is about to begin once more.
The gate to death, Lolithia, will be opened.
A messenger of Armageddon will appear.
But don't give in, you must feed it.
It is your mission.
Ugh!
We gotta defeat Metal, man.
Lolithia, what does it mean?
It's a mission for a Shaman.
No, my mission as Princess of Outerhide awaits me.
So in Japanese, it's so dark, okay.
It's not ogre?
It's so dark sounds much better than sure to dark.
Honestly, yeah, I think so too.
Welcome back, Cecilia.
Sister Mary, did you know?
Yes, I knew, I knew, I know everything.
I know that you're carrying something very heavy too.
Sister, I believe that you all have to face many trials if you are led by the teardrop.
The women of Outerhide, royal family, are born shamans.
Those who can commune with the guardians of this world.
And they are often faced with a hard and difficult path of destiny.
Yes, but even though I'm...
Yes, I know you are always trying to be strong.
No one can do your suffering for you,
but friends can most definitely help to lighten the load.
Cecilia, find friends who can share the burden of your destiny.
And perhaps you will reduce their burdens as well.
Friends, yes, you are right.
I am a princess of Outerhide.
Even if I consider them as friends, but they can do the same to consider me as theirs?
Please tell me, sister.
Is it even possible to find friends that would accept someone like me?
Well, we will see.
Friends are not something you make, but rather something you discover.
Your mother was born in Outerhide, and she was able to find wonderful friends here at the Karan Abbey.
She winked.
Always remember to smile and have faith in yourself.
Everyone else who knows you places their faith in you easily.
You are a princess of Outerhide, but first and foremost, you are your own person.
There are many dictates, there are many dictates and duties,
but in the end, you alone choose your life, you understand?
Yes, I think I'm ready.
Everyone?
I knew that you would have returned to Outerhide's castle when you turned 17 years old.
I didn't know it was today.
I'm sorry.
I was being absent-minded as usual.
Do you have to return so soon?
Well, even though you weren't here long, I'm glad I got to know you.
I'll miss you. We all will.
By Heating the Guardian's Call, she joins the Great Wheel of Destiny as it turns towards the unforeseeable future.
Everyone starts off by following, but eventually, there comes a time when everyone chooses their own path.
The path this girl chose by answering the Guardian's Call will be fraught with danger when she finds her way through.
They always go so fast!
I'm sorry.
Stop happening!
But that was cool.
You brought this trouble on us. We must get rid of him and bring peace back to the village.
Now I've seen the power on first hand. That horrible sound it makes is like the roar of legendary monsters.
If he caused the earthquake, he is too dangerous to stay here. If he did it, he must be punished.
I pity the bullet, but he is a wanderer. He doesn't live the way we do. Maybe he should move on.
He's just a little guy.
I'll make a bomb.
I'm burning this house down!
Dang it.
Oh, dang it.
Well, that didn't work.
Bombs are okay, but gun is not.
Fuck this place.
Yeah, I'm burning your inn down. Fuck you. Wait, there's stuff here.
The world moves to the wilderness.
Sorry, I'm reading now.
How long our world became a wasteland? Long ago, our world filled Gaia was a world filled green.
Our world became a wasteland because of a great battle fought over a thousand years ago.
Destruction was done by alien invaders.
And we now call themans.
Wait a second.
Aliens.
Well, gosh darn it, I'll be damned. They were aliens.
Humans, Elos, Guardians, all the inhabitants of the world bandaged together and fought bravely in defense of Gaia.
There's gosh darn aliens stole my Cal Betsy.
Alas, the impact of the war was tremendous. Many, many people were killed.
Gaia itself was left in ruins.
A final battle and destructive power came into our hands. This power was armed.
It was said that this power originally came from the demons.
In the end, Gaia was victorious. But the price was steep. Thanks to Arm, the world lay in ruins.
Don't you love how I'm reading this dramatic thing and there's still a bomb about to go off in the background?
Hahaha.
It's like the bomb can wait.
The Guardians of Fogaya lost the power they once had to hold the world together.
The lu disappeared, no one knows where, and the humans, saddened by the devastation, see
away forever the destructive power of arm.
It had destroyed as much as it protected.
No one's flourishing civilisation of Fogaya was now lost.
Since the demon, Guardians, aloh and arm were hardly seen again, in Fogaya now.
It's but a barren wasteland.
The Guardians of Fogaya lost the power they once had to hold the world together.
Order! Order!
Okay, hold on.
That was pretty good timing, right?
Order! Order!
The will of the majority is clear.
A boy is banished from the village.
Since I have taken responsibility for him, I will tell him of our decision.
That's it! That's the punishment! He tried to bring a monster down on us!
Wait, he tried to take a monster down on us!
Rudy, are you eavesdropping? It's alright.
The village has reached its decision. As soon as you're ready, he must leave Surf Village.
Homeowners Association hate!
Also, yeah, we killed that monster.
Head Foss, head Farsal.
Go to the other side of the mountains. Face in the sea, find a grove.
On the grove, find the Kingdom of Adahide.
So wanderer, you may find that a big city has more to offer you than a small lonely village on the frontier.
He's so sad!
We saved your kid, you're your kid.
We saved your kid, and we've defeated a demon, and now it's like, get out! Get!
And now they went, get! Get out of our village! We don't take kindly to your con!
Blue hair, anime protagonist.
I'm sorry.
Hey, okay.
Hey mister!
What's a dog doing?
You really helped me, but, but I couldn't help you.
I know you're a good person, no one listens to me though. I'm just a kid.
And life is a nightmare.
I, I wanted to at least say thank you.
Yeah, the dog lived!
Somebody wants to admit it to you, but everybody knows you saved my life.
I should go home now. Thanks again, Mr. Wanderer. I'll never forget you.
Do we get the fruit, Tim?
Duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh.
Hold on.
I literally cannot save.
Shoot!
What was the...
Right, I had to go do this.
The return of gun.
What the fuck are you? Rat monkey!
Gaggy sun.
I don't feel like those are rats.
I think you literally do not look like rats.
Maybe I can see sort of the monkey part because I just saw their bare butts.
Like, you see those butts? Very detailed. Very, very chimp-like.
What the fuck are you doing?
Why the cake?
Why?
I'm not gonna be able to find like a...
I'm not gonna be able to find things as easily.
Die!
I did take a primate study course.
I don't really have a favorite, like, primate.
But I felt kind of sad after coming out of that course.
Because I found out, like, at the end of the day, I found out that I had a primate study course.
I found out that I had a primate study course.
Because I found out, like, at the time, like, over 80% of all, like, primate populations have become extinct.
Like, species.
And that made me really sad.
Made me really sad.
I'm not bad.
Oh, we're cool. Oh, we're okay.
So that made me really sad.
And that was my take away, is that I was like, man, it sucks.
It sucks that, like, you know...
Is there anything here?
This is the weirdest tech.
I can't...
She...
Here?
Oh, this music's great.
These are kinda like, lost.
Dude.
What the heck is this supposed to be?
Wait, condition sickness?
I hope it doesn't last.
Is there a place here?
Oh, come on!
I can't save until I see a guy, a little guy, you know?
A huge map.
Was it hard?
For the first game, did you just have to, like, run into place and be like, oh, I found
it?
Yeah, Gimmel coins can let you save at any time.
That's true, too, but aren't they kind of, like, precious?
I am too far.
I'm not healing in close battle?
The original locations were on the map in plain sight.
Why did they take that?
Why did they take that away from me?
What do these do?
I don't know what these do!
Medicine.
You mean because I'm sick?
Okay, I guess it does.
Oh, thank you.
Well, Kango did work.
I hate this mechanic right now.
Like, legit, do not like this mechanic.
Like, I don't like having to go close to too much work, man.
There's out a hide.
I'm lost.
I want a map.
Stink cloud, thanks.
I got a map you had to walk to the other forest.
Which forest?
This one?
This one.
There are trees here.
Where the fuck you go?
I'm not going to lie to you!
This is a dumb mechanic.
This is dumb.
Super dumb mechanic.
It literally had to materialize.
We literally walked through that, yeah.
Get out of my way!
We have an emergency.
There was an accident at the site.
Get out of control.
We need to let Emma know.
I don't know you guys.
You need to take me to the nearest hospital first.
I'm hungry.
There it is!
Hello, where are you?
Hello there!
Are you asking me to save your progress?
Yeah.
You are in Aldehi, a trading mecca with a truly sparkling culture.
You must be here for the ancient culture exhibition.
I find this town as lovely as I do.
Please feel free to look around.
Emma, come on.
Welcome, let me upgrade your arm!
Dr. Emma, even study is under me.
We do have a lot of money.
Should we do a DAC bonus?
Or more bullets?
I'm going to do more bullets.
I don't know what easiness is.
Tune's reflexes counter and equips auto-reload.
Amplified power when a critical hit occurs.
Increases shot accuracy.
Increases shot attacking power.
Is accuracy more important?
Is there a chance that I'll miss?
Haven't missed yet, but is there a chance I'll miss later?
Critical easiness?
I don't know.
The attack bonus sounds nice, but it's a lot of gala.
It's a lot of gala.
My name.
What the heck is this?
How may I help you?
Feel free to create magic as long as there's a spot on the crest graph.
Huh?
I'm sorry, I'm afraid you're not allowed to create any magic without a crest sorcerer.
Alright.
Welcome, please take a look around.
Oh, it's got medicine here.
I'm good.
Bye-bye.
We'll see you soon.
I headcanon everyone here.
Everyone here has an accent.
Come on.
Yep, we can see.
Antique shelf.
Li-well.
Organized small machine parts of his Darko's significance.
Okay.
Can I go into here?
Can I just go into people's buildings?
The poster shows out a hide from a bird's eye view.
Oh, hey, is that the princess?
The princess!
You look like a wanderer.
That's exciting to be able to travel so freely.
H bird can only look up at the sky and admire your strong wings.
Fish, why?
Fish, why are you like giving me poetry?
Welcome.
Welcome, you will.
You will enjoy our cozy room
and our exceptional complimentary soup.
Soup!
Thank you for staying with us.
Now, meet 35 Geluf, all of you.
No.
Am I saying soup weird, Senpai?
I don't think so.
This town is huge, almost too huge,
but I figured there'll be a job for me.
I could not have been more wrong.
The only job I have for me is to dig around the ruins.
Do you think a wanderer wants to dig around the ruins?
Oh, you're a wanderer too.
Ah, shucks.
They always give me the ability to go on the balcony,
but there's nothing on the balcony.
This game loves it.
Sorry.
Empty balcony.
Done.
You know that the ancient cultural exhibition is opening soon?
Can't wait.
I've been saving my allowance for a long time for this.
I got this cute purse for my grandma.
It goes around my neck, so I won't lose my money.
That is really sweet and cute.
Anything?
I feel...
Is there anything cool?
No.
You have all these hidden areas,
but there's like nothing.
Not a safe way to hold on to money though.
Yeah, probably.
Here lies the tombstone of Selduks.
This guardian protected the castle
and symbolizes defense and stability.
Like, kinda looks like wasted,
wasted, like, map room, right?
It's okay.
Okay.
A boy with an arm.
I tend to grow suspicious when I hear the word arm.
I heard there are people who specialize in the profession of arm modification.
I think they're called Armmeister.
Armmeister?
Snowmeister, hee, meister.
We all have arms.
In fact, that's true.
Well, some of us might not have arms,
and some of us might have one arm.
From what I hear, they're always busy.
It's not just keeping myself too busy all the time.
I don't know how anyone can be so passionate.
Wait a second.
We get kicked out of the small village
because we own an arm,
but it's, like, common in this world?
What?
It's hair.
I knew it.
It's like, we don't take kindly to your kind around here,
specifically anime protagonist blue hair.
I just wanted to reason to kick us out.
I know, right?
So rude.
My husband has been saying all along,
we shouldn't let our guard down because monsters are lurking in the shadows
just waiting for a chance to attack.
I just don't think it's wise.
This time I have an exhibition of our town.
It just got me a little worried.
Why don't we have secret spots?
Why don't we have spots that look like they would go to cool places
and have squashed up, but they don't.
I worry a lot.
It's the nature of my profession.
My wife doesn't like it, though.
Every time I raise any concern,
she tells me to zip it before I can even finish my sentence.
The title is,
book is titled The Two Moons.
Do you want to read it?
Yeah.
It is nothing new for the people in Phil Gaia
to see two shining moons in the cloudless night sky.
A tale would have had, would have it,
that one of the moons was created by humans 1,000 years ago.
Wait, we got fake moons and time is made by machines?
What?
People call the old moon, old moon,
and the man-made moon, new moon.
This world building is wild, yeah.
A thousand years ago,
it's not only marked as the period of great war,
but also as the period of great progress in technology.
It was the age when no one wondered
how humans were able to create another moon in the sea of stars.
We can only lament at the sad,
at the sad fact that modern men are unable
to verify the authenticity of this tale.
I think I'm getting eepy some pie.
Inscription reads,
to commemorate the new,
the inauguration of the new out-of-hide mayor.
It's a little wild, right?
Oh, this must be the castle.
Only, only the exhibition staff is allowed in this point,
in at this point, sorry for the inconvenience.
Okay, well, this place is.
Oh, it is like, yeah.
Hold on, let me save then.
I think I want to wrap it up soon.
It's good that we got to another place,
so let's go on like this half
before we go into like the castle,
and then that's it for today, I think.
I think we're doing, the prologue is pretty good.
Um, it's funny that we only,
we only completed the prologue,
and then after the prologue would be,
we would complete the, um,
I'm assuming they go by chapters?
Yeah.
Oh, let me talk, let me talk.
I just saw a traveling knight enter,
enter out of Hyde Castle.
You think he's here to apply for a security job
at the Ancient Culture Exhibition?
It was a pretty long prologue,
but it's not like I minded too much.
Oh, book.
There has not been many patients here lately.
Thanks to Ferguson,
I can actually use some of this equipment.
Book.
I don't, anyone can be stronger.
We need this book, Senpai.
How can I become stronger?
Is it by remaining righteous?
No, I don't think so.
If you increase your numbers,
you will become stronger in no time.
In other words, form a faction.
Don't get down is very effective,
and the quickest way.
A faction, or call it a party.
Aw, man.
Once a party is formed,
you are immediately stronger
with the combined traits of each member.
This guy has such a great punch.
That guy is popular with the ladies.
That guy's relative is an influential politician.
Anything goes.
It's very important to respect everyone's unique power.
A strong party understands each other.
Yes, I like what I just said.
Well, I'm on a roll.
I'm going to add one more thing.
To understand each other also means
to be accepting of one's flaws,
as well as one's good traits.
I would even recommend having each other,
each member anonymously write down
their flaws and openly discuss it afterwards.
Find that there is an abundance of words
to describe flaws.
Be an ugly discussion for sure.
Be angry people.
Anger can make one stronger,
especially for those who want to get strong quickly.
I see.
You have learned that
spite and anger
makes you stronger.
I'm starting to see more
small scratches on my body.
I'm starting not to
trust this nun.
I feel like I'm better off without any of her treatments.
Wait, what?
What have you been doing?
Oh my gosh.
It's like shady.
What if I start walking in?
Why did nobody stop me?
What the hell?
Okay.
This one I can go through.
Out of hide castles, open up.
Anyone who wants to visit, that means you too.
The king's belief in democracy
over dictatorship shall be phrased.
Okay, well, we're good.
His name is Cougar.
Oh, this looks real needle.
Look at that.
I'm a little dizzy, though,
from this angle.
Sometimes you will see people
getting lost in this huge castle.
That's why the audience chamber
is located in the front of the entrance.
Though you appear to be younger than me,
you must have seen five times as many towns
as I ever have.
I'm envious to say the least. Just not right.
I mean, I know one hundred,
one thousand five hundred times
more about the castle,
but I bet you're not even slightly envious of me.
There.
What's up, biatch?
Mercy, that's the king.
I know.
This is a democracy, right?
With your help,
the Ancient Culture Exhibition Exhibition.
It could be a huge success.
I speak for all of Audehide.
When I say, your help is greatly appreciated.
Let me talk.
A legend you'll find
will go a long way towards
making this kind of tree prosperous.
Wanderers will be keeping an eye
on your progress.
Can we talk?
Are you here for deco?
Yes, though I have earned the right
to be his majesty's bodyguard.
Ever since I was a child,
I always wanted to wear Gar's uniform.
Just when I became a guard,
I was eliminated to cut down on expenses.
Wow.
That sucks.
Only the elite can be an Audehide knight.
We would willingly sacrifice our lives
for his majesty.
Pledge our loyalty only to King Justin.
I didn't expect that to be a name.
Like, that is...
I don't know.
Senpai, Justin is not really
a kingly name, right?
It's not really a kingly name,
is it?
So, I knew statues,
but they were not fixed or stabilized.
I added him for that. Perhaps I was too harsh on him
because he's not here now.
I don't understand young people.
Short for King Justin...
Justinian.
I think Justinian would be better.
Yeah.
But like, Justin is, you know...
Justin just doesn't seem...
Kingly.
Uh, Justin Saiyan.
What the heck is this?
Just incredible. Amazing.
I don't know if it's
Adelhide?
Or...
Whatever, hide.
I want to say...
I was saying Adelhide, right?
Probably like Lado, like...
Adel?
I always said...
Adel, like Lado too.
Bitch, I'm coming in!
Imagine.
Fuck.
Literally.
Literally, just like...
Somebody was coming!
I am the worst.
You know she felt me.
Wait!
That's a fake door!
That's fucking rude.
This is the soldier...
This is the soldier's quarters.
If you don't mind, you have to excuse us.
There are things in here I do not wish
any lady to see.
Any lady?
Title...
Troll control.
Oi, mods!
Take notes!
I appreciate you, mods.
Let's take notes.
A large monster known as Troll
lives in dark mountains
shrouded in darkness.
The troll has
mass of physical strength
and great survival skill.
The following information
is what you should know
about the Troll control.
If you are skilled,
feel free to fight it.
Because if the troll's life
in darkness,
it will fear light.
One flash may lead to victory.
Another known as Troll control.
The Troll control.
Another known fact
is that the troll is cautious
and careful.
Unless provoked, the troll will not attack.
I think that's a lie.
Therefore, if you are not a skilled fighter
it will be wise to leave the troll room.
Never mind! Do not listen!
Never mind! Do not listen
to this!
Do not listen to this!
No! That was terrible!
That was terrible advice!
What the hell?
Anatomy of the Demon.
Moderators, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Please continue
to do what you keep doing best.
I clearly this game knows nothing
and you know better.
No!
With their cold, solid steel bodies.
Steel!
The alien invaders are known
as demons.
Are they living metal then?
These like...
Aliens?
Are they robots?
From the outside, they look like monsters
but their inside anatomy
closely resembles that
of people in Fogaya.
They are constructed
of different materials than the human body
but their internal systems
operate much the same way.
They're people?
They're robot people?
They are aliens,
demons, and
robots?
A prehistoric alchemist
attempted to obtain demon power
by conducting a series
of experiments on a captured demon.
The alchemist's process
and action seemed very
eccentric now but the world was
in a constant state of war.
From the demon,
the alchemist created a newly
living organism he called
a golem.
Alas, the golem was merely a prototype
of the nightmare the alchemist
eventually created.
The lore is wild!
I kind of like it, you know?
So, what have you been hiding?
Are you looking at naughty things?
Did you hide it under your mattress?
Where do you hide it?
Where do you hide it, senpai?
It's a secret?
Oh, I keep it in the open?
Is this a trick question?
Nothing too hide, I have to hide
my stuff, obviously.
Your FB is your spirit.
You can only be increased
with your experiences in battle.
I believe I should tell all of my
junior fellows the same thing.
What's up with these fake doors?
The dining room?
What's behind curtain number one?
Nothing.
Oh,
I can see behind.
Oh, looks like I
hid stuff.
I hate these freaking fake doors.
I've never played Silent Hill before.
That room does seem important.
I've always been my job to look
out for after the princess.
That's why I'm so concerned.
Please be safe.
I'm having a hard time dealing with this.
I must put my fingers aside and wish the best for you.
Okay.
Demon Star
Yiddies.
Yiddies?
Are a best way to pronounce that?
After many years of
studies, humans and illo
have finally located the demon's
home base.
Their world is far away in a different
dimension.
Yiddies nuts, shut up.
You don't get to say it.
Only I can say it.
I think it's
Yiddies though.
Hades though.
On a star named Hades, or the full name Saturn Hades, it might be Hades, but Hades sounds
cool too.
Hi Hades, is it Hades?
Hi Hades breeds, monster, and is in a constant state of war.
The continuous battle caused the inevitable destruction of Hi Hades.
After being banished from Hi Hades, the monsters wander through dimensions until they eventually
found Fogaya, a demon fought for a new home, or the people of Fogaya fought to preserve
their homeland in the Great Demon War.
Kind of makes you sympathize them, huh?
The book of Kima.
You might not shut up, you don't get to say it.
It makes them feel pretty sad if they just want to find a home.
This book contains this secret, which one woman once was granted from up above.
The creation of a superhuman involves the experiments of an ancient alchemist which
shall never be replicated.
That's it.
Apparently in the first game, not the remake, which I'm playing right now, but the first
game.
They had really bad translations, so apparently some of the names are really funky.
I've never played a game this game, what's it about?
I think most people would call this a Western RPG, like, you know, Shurentoon.
A Western JRP, yes.
Truton and Shuton, I forgot.
They made it like, what the, what the, copy, copy past the, hold on, let me google it.
What do you want to know now?
It's like based off of like, Boyle.
Oh, here, I don't remember what it was, Rootin, Tootin, Cowboy, Shutin.
It's like Boyle, Boyle, Coyle and Trouble, I have Newt and, I can't remember the rest
of it, oh well, whatever, which is, yeah, but it was like a parody, but like Cowboys,
you know, it's like Rootin, Tootin, Cowboy, Shutin, yeah, Rootin, Tootin, Toilin, Shutin,
no peeking in advance, okay, yeah, it's from the play, but like, they paradised it using
Cowboys instead, I can't find the copy pasta anymore, it was fun though, and I thought
it was very charming, I thought it was very charming.
And now I don't know what to do, like, do I go back into here and be like, sup, bia?
Do I go to sleep and make it the next day?
You'll find it searching Cowboys as witches, oh, hold on, I'll read it now, oh, I see it,
Rootin, Tootin, Toilin, Toilin, Shutin, Fireburn and Cowboy, Bootin, I have Newton, Spicy Beans,
Toalfrog and Denim Jeans, Whiskey Grit and Demon Spittle tossed in my iron griddle, with
the tannin of our hide, something wicked this way rides, I thought it was great,
we need mercy as a cowboy witch fan art now, this town, wait, this broom ain't big enough
for the two of us, okay, I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna do the attack bonus,
I'm gonna upgrade, upgrade, upgrade all of it,
sure, should I, I guess we'll spend the night, maybe I'll, oh, nice little tune, okay, while
that fucking did a shit all, you play this on the OG console, oh fuck you, this is the
OG console, I'm playing on original hardware, this is, I'm playing with the disc, we are
on the PS2 right now, oh, Azorah, who's cute me, oh shucks,
what are you doing out Azorah, hold on, what are you doing out Azorah, didn't you be getting
some rest right about now, I am a little confused about where I'm supposed to go,
I want to move on to the next part, but I'm also kind of confused,
why'd you let me go so far, straight ahead is King's family room, please refrain from
entering there, why'd you let me go so far then, rest, I feel like you should rest,
damn pie, what am I supposed to do, almost locked up, right, but how is that,
oh yeah, we gotta track those two fellas, didn't they say they were gonna go see the
King or, no wait they were going to see, were they gonna see, a woman's name, I remember
it was a woman's name, yeah I thought they left the guy at the nun's place,
whoa, I wanted to go get to the next part at least,
where'd they go,
you have to go to the city part, this part,
you want a hint, yeah I want a hint, middle building, this one, I didn't finish exploring the
arm shop, thank, oh hi, I thought that was odd to it, this one,
oh shit that would be so hard to see that is hard to see that fucking cat
Cutscene! Just heard some promotions, everything alright? Check, check.
Kind of exciting isn't it? Y'all have to urge the staff and look at accidents on the street.
Boss Emergency! There's been an incident up north at Lollithia's coffin!
Oh no, not the excavation site. Quickly tell me what happened.
Damage done by the earthquake was much greater than anticipated.
Part of the wall collapsed in the quake and monsters have come out onto the site.
Some of the workers were attacked by the monsters but no one's been killed yet.
Organize a group, drive out those monsters.
No can do boss, none of the workers have any experience fighting monsters.
Besides, they have us outnumbered. They're too much for us.
I see. You leave the monsters to me then.
In the meantime, get back to work! Pour our efforts into restoring the ruins!
The exhibition is coming up. I'm determined to bring Lollithia back after a thousand years of sleep.
Yes ma'am!
I don't know, I kind of like pink and green. It's kind of a very, I think, lilymon?
Okay, now that you've heard, there's trouble at my site.
And here you are a young wanderer, no doubt you false monsters. You're share of monsters.
Would you agree to do a little house cleaning with those monsters in the ruins?
I believe it will be a great opportunity for you to study at Lollithia's coffin too.
Do we ever show any interest in, like, as Rudy? Have we shown any interest in Lollithia's coffin?
I can give you 5,000 yellow, payable upon your success. That's not a bad offer, is it?
Okay, maybe 5,000 sounds pretty good, actually.
This seems like dialogue for Gack.
Yeah, Rudy really likes Lollithia. I don't think we ever, we ever showed any interest, huh?
Oh, for money, maybe. You make it, like, 10,000 yellow, that'd be nice.
Should we agree? Or, it's too dangerous to accept?
Add juice too for the lulls.
Please understand, it won't be easy. The artifact must be excavated from those ruins for the upcoming exhibition.
At least 5,000 yellow is a very good reward, considering the risk involved.
We have the illusion of choice once again.
Good, I knew you would take it.
It senses inadvertent involvement in the earthquake, which caused the accident.
You look as if you blame yourself for what transpired. Maybe investigating this will help you too.
In any case, we need to focus on our tasks.
I am Emma Hetfield.
I'm in charge of excavating the artifact. I'm actually an engineer. I like to work on machines.
I'm off to the excavation site up north, where Lollithia is located. This is a dangerous place, so please be well prepared. I cannot stress this enough.
I will meet you there. If I were you, I would gather up a group before you head up.
We have no choice. She's quite tall. Don't you like tall women?
I think Azura and Chibi are taller than me.
We're partying now.
So that means we found someone, so that's it.
There you go.
Are you heading for Lollithia's coffin? I too am drawn by the word Lollithia.
Drawing to the word Lollithia, huh?
Hehehehehehe.
You'll change connection with it.
Can I accompany you to Lalitha's coffin?
I am Cecilia.
I'm familiar with the Crest Sorcery,
the Crest Graph, and it's possible to cast
various magic spells as needed.
I have the Crest Graph with me.
Across from the Lodge is the Magic Guild,
where we can edit the list of magic spells.
The more spells we have on our hand,
the more ways we can handle different situations
which will occur.
Cecilia, join the party.
Have anyone read the book?
I thought it was a very good book.
Well, you're still streaming.
What can I say?
Wild arms, a sail like Cyan.
How may I help you?
Can I edit hack spells?
What the heck is this?
Best to see the effects of this magic.
Make the Crush Magic spell cost you 60 Gellas.
Sure.
I've only watched the movie, the Stanley Kubrick movie.
You can rename spells, can you?
Looks like you can, Tempai.
Let's return spell.
No, I don't want support magic.
Who do we have?
We have Cecilia, Rudy, have we encountered Jack yet?
Probably not, right?
I feel like...
Jack was back in the cast of Shit.
We did.
May I did talk to him?
Fuck, was he?
I forgore!
The treasure door.
You're so right.
You're so right, Bestie.
Totally forgot.
Anyway, here's Johnny!
Wait, which way was I supposed to go?
Oh, there.
Her Bestie status were more than Bestie's.
Oh, right there!
Oops.
I wasn't going anywhere with the locked door in front of me.
Wait, you don't work for the castle, you scare me like that.
Okay, you're another wanderer.
I know where I can make some money or maybe find some treasure.
What?
You're after Lolithia.
You said Lolithia, right?
Hoping to have.
We also happened to have some business with Lolithia.
We happened to be on our way there.
I'm Jack, my companion is Hanpan.
Like it or not, we're coming with you.
Jack joined the party.
He totally was gonna rule the king.
We only have Jack, Rudy, and Cecilia, right?
Wait, can Cecilia go into that magic room?
Probably not.
Let's feel safe.
And then the adventure in Athos.
And then the adventure at the excavation site will be left for another stream.
Why do you think so, Pie?
We uh, eat, eat, wait.
We saves.
And then eat.
I think I just have to...
Uh, what's the word?
I think I just have to turn off the PS2, right?
I can just turn it off?
Okay.
Yeah, okay, let's turn it off then.
There we go.
Aw, quiet now.
There's no quick game mechanics.
We're talking old school.
We're talking old school, Senpai.
I've never had a PS2 before. I've used it a few times, but I just can't remember.
I didn't grow up with it, Senpai.
Also, my chat's not working, it looks like.
No more cowboy hat. The cowboy hat's sitting on my head sideways.
I forgot.
Never bought a console. My first console was a...
PS4.
And the PS4, to turn off the PS4, you go to the home menu and then you go to, like...
You scroll all the way to power and then it's, like, sleep or shut down, I think. Something like that.
I can't quite remember, but...
That was my first... system?
My first, like, game console was the DS.
The DS Lite. And the DS Lite, you know, you had to save.
I guess you could, you could technically, yeah, it was fine if you just held the button, right?
You held the button and could just turn off.
But, like, I wasn't too sure, because they all work differently, right?
So, I was like, oh, wait. I can't remember.
I was playing with this earlier, but now my brain is mush.
My brain is mush.
It's always different from one console to another. Yeah, like, for example, the Switch, like, to turn it off, you got to go all the way to the side and go, like, oh, put it to sleep, right?
I loved, uh...
I loved the, uh... what do you call it?
I love the DS, but I want to experience your childhood to Senpai.
So, I'm going to be trying to play retro games and catching up on games that I, um, I never got to play as a kid.
I never got to play as a kid.
I only got the DS because, uh, Mama and Papa Mercy were like, they saw the cover show, but they were a big brain academy, and they were like, okay, we can get you one, and that was it.
Literally the only reason why I was able to get any game system.
I... yeah, that's the only reason why I got it, and then my first game game was Pokemon Pearl.
Yeah, it was Pokemon Pearl.
I was still quite, quite older.
I was quite, uh, older than, than, like, you know, at the age that people are like, oh, when did you get into Pokemon?
I wasn't the age... I wasn't at the age that I was a bit older.
I was a bit older for the demographic, I guess.
I made me 14?
Wait.
Forgetty Beam!
Boom!
Huh?
We were not talking about anything.
I heard something about battle network, battle network, like Mega Man?
Like Mega Man?
Mega Man Battle Network.
Oh, I was watching, uh, Mew from Speciality play, uh, Mega Man X, the Mega Man X series.
Um...
It was really good at it, actually.
Battle Network is completely different, is it?
Is it?
I've only seen speed runners play, like, Mega Man games.
I haven't actually seen Mega Man play normally.
I actually have, uh, a few friends who are Mega Man speed runners.
So, I'm just, like, I've never seen it play normally, but I've only seen the ones where they have, like, glitches and stuff, and people, like, paged through walls or, like, beaten enemy really fast.
I've only seen that version.
I feel like I will be, like, a very distorted view if I play...
If I try to play any Mega Man game, because then I'll just be trying to, like, emulate the speed runners.
That's what I feel like I would end up doing.
Oh my gosh, actually my brain is so mushy right now.
I think a six hour stream is pretty freaking good.
Uhhhhhhhhhhhhh.
Give me a second.
I am soul?
Dummy.
Right now.
Give me a second. I think I'm very dummy right now.
What is my schedule?
Tomorrow!
Or, rather, today!
I will be doing a member's watch along.
Uh, we're all going to be watching Eagle Eye, which is not a great film, but one that's close to my heart.
One that made me really, really appreciate film and really got me into, like, entertainment in general.
This would be the domino effect.
Eagle Eye is what made me into a VTuber.
The reason why I'm here.
So, we'll do a member's watch along for Eagle Eye.
And then, on Saturday, I have the VLR rating VTubers design.
That will be, I believe, on Icy's channel.
And, then, I know I wrote something, there was nothing for Sunday, but I totally forgot to plan it.
But there is a watch party.
A watch along party.
Um,
For Umeb Plus's Dream Come True concert that I'm really looking forward to.
So, uh, that's around, what time is the Umeb Plus concert?
I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
5pm PDT.
Is that 5pm PDT?
So, uh, convert that as you wish.
So, you can watch the Umeb Plus concert with me if you wanted.
Or with any of my other gen mates, I think only a couple of them aren't participating, I can't remember quite so well.
Brain too mushy right now to actually recall anything.
Thoughts, head empty.
I'm looking forward to it, I'm looking forward to it.
So, I hope to see you all there, I hope you can also watch the concert live as well, maybe put it on another screen.
Yeah, put it on another screen, maybe try a...
Are you doing a watch along for that here?
Uh, I believe so, yes, I'll do, I believe I am doing a watch along on my channel.
So, feel free to take a peak season pie.
So, I'll be streaming my PLV and reacting to the Umeb Plus girls.
I've talked to them behind the scenes and they've worked really hard to bring you a wonderful concert.
So, yeah, I'm looking forward to that.
And then, I guess on the same Sunday I'll post up my new schedule.
The following week, as a preview for the following week, it's going to be a bit of a shorter week for me at least.
So, I'm looking forward to taking a tiny, tiny, tiny break because I've been kind of like working a lot lately.
I've been working a lot lately, so sometimes my days off are not really days off and I'm doing a lot of stuff behind the scenes.
Like, for example, like my day off, I was working on setting this all up for Senpai and running to get the PS2.
It was like an odd day thing.
God, I'm so tired.
So, hopefully, we get to play more games.
I'm looking forward to returning back to Wild Arms.
I hope Senpai's are too.
What do you think of Wild Arms?
Was it fun?
Like the Ultra Cold F?
Was it good?
Did you like it?
I hope you liked it.
Because I do want to return to it.
But I'm not sure if, like, Senpai's liked it.
So, I was like, oh well, if it wasn't that fun, maybe.
Maybe, maybe we can, you know, yeah.
I think, I think if there's like a lot of grinding work, I'll do that off-stream to make it easier for Senpai.
Hopefully, it's not too long of a game.
I'm hoping.
RPGs tend to be very long games and that's one thing I don't like about RPGs is that they're very, very, very long.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't think anyone's on, obviously.
It's probably super late right now.
Yeah.
So, I'll leave you awe to the Abyss of Silence.
Wait, the Silence of the Abyss?
I think that's a better way to say it.
I'll see you all again next time.
Okay?
Wow!
Scream for Mercy!
Weeeeee!
Thank you for watching!